foreign
okay
sorry about my tardiness here please
don't report me to the speaker
okay we will open up this very
informative presentation uh from the
insurance department that'll tell us all
the secrets that go on behind closed
doors
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Jason Aziz I'm the
director of Health economics at the New
Hampshire insurance department and it's
so nice to meet you this way
I would also like to thank you for the
privilege to present some valuable
information to you
some of which may help to inform the
important policy decisions that lie in
front of you New Hampshire is considered
a Pioneer state in terms of data-driven
health care information
we were among the first states to
implement an all-payer claims database
in fact Alex felve and representative
hunt were Central forces in the
legislation authorizing the
establishment of this database which we
now refer to as the New Hampshire chis
we've taken the Liberty to prepare for
you a document and a set of slides that
will advance your understanding of the
New Hampshire chiz in some of his
outputs
we've also prepared some copies for
interested members of the audience
please flip through the pages while
we've talked briefly about several
important concepts related to the
medical claims data
my goal is to not talk about each and
every slide but to give you a 10 000
foot overview of what the New Hampshire
chiz is all about in New Hampshire
Health cost
and to leave opportunity plenty of
opportunity for people to ask questions
the first couple slides talks about the
statutory Authority and confidentiality
issues in the all pairs claims database
RSA 420 G11 authorized the insurance
department to collect this data from his
commercial carriers
the New Hampshire insurance department
DHHS and doj have a data use in Sharing
mou or memorandum memorandum of
understanding or use of the New
Hampshire chis the data is twice
de-identified and HIPAA rules of
confidentiality apply
researchers all around the country May
request public use and limited use forms
of the data through an Apple application
process which is currently managed by
DHHS
so what is the chis
it's a robust data set consisting of
medical dental and prescription claims
data
every quarter New Hampshire insurance
department and DHHS as well as the UNH
Institute of Health policy and practice
receives quarterly updates
when you're trying to understand data
you always want to think about who what
and when who does the data represent
what does it represent in what periods
of time is it representative
this includes claims from commercial
payers Medicaid and opt-in erisa plans
which are self-insured in the state
some important variables are listed
below the most important one I've
highlighted it's the allowed amount when
we hear about prices and costs and paid
amounts usually we're referring to
allowed amounts but in addition there
are some other quantitative parameters
including build them out paid amount and
cost sharing contributions such as copay
deductible and coinsurance
there's also procedure codes diagnosis
codes and indicator variables for
insurance Market category provider NPI
in member demographic information we're
working to make more robust our our
variable for drgs which is diagnostic
related groups which it can give us a
better sense of some of the more complex
variables in the chis database
medical claims data is inherently not
straightforward so having the drg
parameter well developed will give us a
better sense of the holistic cost of an
encounter with a healthcare provider
foreign
to put into perspective the size of the
database I mentioned the three claims
files medical dental and prescription
the medical claims contains 117
variables prescription claims 130
variables and dental claims 122
variables
currently data extracts are
retrospective from 2012 to 2022.
so who who uses the New Hampshire chis
and how do they use it we'll start with
the New Hampshire insurance department
our most important use for the chiz is
to derive rates for New Hampshire Health
costs which we'll talk about in a few
moments
we also use this data to assess New
Hampshire provider Network adequacy
in fact New Hampshire has a very
Innovative empirically based Network
adequacy review process
we also use the chiz to support
legislative policy making for example to
review the costs of State mandates
and to support the work of legislative
commissions so can you um explain could
we have a lot of new members what
network adequacy means generically in
specifically why it's important to the
Department
um since the Advent of managed care
where health insurance coverage is
offered through the development of a
network
um where the consumer has a financial
incentive to get their care from within
that Network the issue has has become
important of the adequacy of that
Network to serve all of the potential
needs of the insured population
so when Managed Care came about within a
few years all the states began to
develop standards for adequacy of
network and those are usually expressed
in terms of time and distance so for
various provider types or service types
there are standards for how long it
would take to access that provider and
how close they are to you
so those standards are developed
authorized in legislation in New
Hampshire and developed through a
specific rule
is that good enough
thanks thank you
we also use the chiz data to conduct
Market conduct examinations such as the
mental health parity exams that are
underway as we speak now
and additionally every year we're
required to produce an annual report on
premium rates and cost drivers in health
care and we use the chiz data as a
primary source of information for that
report
Additionally the New Hampshire
Department of Justice uses the chiz data
to perform Market concentration analyzes
as part of Anti-Trust examinations
they do this under the New Hampshire
charitable Trust
they also use it to identify pricing
anomalies that may be suggestive of
Monopoly power
and lastly the New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human Services
uses the chiz data to release to public
to inform researchers regulators and
even citizens on health care costs
they use it to Compare costs among New
Hampshire Medicaid plans and also to
inform legislative bodies like yours
so now I'd like to discuss one of the
outputs one of the primary outputs of
the chis data New Hampshire Health cost
you've heard much about it in testimony
in the last several weeks so I'd like to
kind of tell you a little bit about it
and form inform you on what it is how we
derive rates for it and the hopes that
will stimulate questions from you after
this presentation
so New Hampshire Health cost is a
trusted free website created by the New
Hampshire insurance department that
connects over 250 000 people per year to
information on health care and insurance
it Compares cost but more than 250
common medical dental
and prescription services including MRIs
CT scans mammograms x-rays ultrasounds
and er visits
it also Compares quality for hospitals
across the state it includes patient
satisfaction ratings
it can be used to compare benefits using
an interactive customizable tool for
small and large employers and their
employees as well as their families
currently there were over 269 services
on listed on New Hampshire Health costs
queries
for cost may be stratified by insurance
carrier including the uninsured and plan
type individual or group
you can Browse by procedure keyword or
enter a specific procedure code
so New Hampshire Health costs has been
criticized much for the price
variability that that some users have
seen I'd like to inform you about some
of the sources of variability that are
that are inherent in medical claims data
and translated into New Hampshire Health
cost
price variation can exist as a product
of how hospitals bundle this Services
about half of the services listed on
health costs are expressed as bundled
Services oftentimes when you go to a
provider it's not just one service
that's performed it's a series of common
Services we try to get Precision in our
price estimates by bundling them in
these Common Market baskets or packages
called bundles
case complexity or also called case mix
intensity is an expression of how sick
you are how sick the patient is this can
be a major factor that drives
variability in price estimates
the number of visits per procedure not
all procedures are produced in one visit
some require multiple visits and this
can can
inject much bias into the price
estimates
as well as the frequency of procedures
and the historical lack of price
transparency in other competitive forces
can all collectively collude to result
in price dispersion or Price variability
which is what we see sometimes in in
health costs let me just interject that
at this point in time a lot of other
states also have all payer claims
databases
and they have similar findings with
respect to the tremendous variability
that can exist for the same procedure
from one provider to the next so that's
a consistent motif
so the next couple slides gives you
examples of of how services that are
bundled or independent are expressed on
health costs this first example
um is an example of arthroscopic knee
surgery and you can see why price
variability here ranging from 3700 to 12
000 I like to point out a measure on
health costs called typical patient
complexity that serves as a good example
to to see why such price variability
exists notice how the higher price price
estimates are associated with higher
patient complexities
the next example
um is an example of a lab test called
pth or parathyroid hormone and you can
see that price ranges vary from 33 to
564 dollars which is a very wide
relative difference with the Statewide
average being 52 dollars
so so when you have the Precision of the
cost
does that mean how precise this number
is when the upper up or down does that
mean how confident you are that this is
the right number or what what is that or
is that is relative to everybody in his
group thank you for the question that's
that's good that that um variable that
output is a product of a measure across
all of the data points for that service
right and we use the coefficient of
variation it's somewhat similar to a
standard deviation or a standard error
in statistics so we use the coefficient
of variation the smaller coefficient of
variation results in higher Precision of
an estimate and if something is wildly
variable like you saw on the knee
arthroscopy example that would have a
large coefficient of variation in a less
precise estimate
right well like I'm looking at this pth
which is could be can't be any simpler
than just a test right and then I'm
saying uh littleton's 313 well that's
low and then weeks Medical Center 332
very low so what is that telling me
so measures of variation like for
example like the coefficient of low
versus very low and but one is higher
than the other so those are rankings of
the size of the coefficient of variation
so the it's hard to express that to fund
statistics
okay
you wanna try one more time why explain
to me so what is that what does that
tell me
that do I
mean
ah okay that's what I was trying to get
at
it
that's what that's what I was hoping it
is about that establishment not
comparing it to anybody else okay okay
good thank you hi hi thanks for taking
my question
um I know that you have another page
where I mean part where you can see the
quality of the hospital is there
anywhere that links the pricing to the
quality of this particular department or
this procedure because you could pay you
know three thousand dollars or six
thousand dollar in the three thousand I
mean the six thousand dollar one
potentially I mean maybe higher quality
and they get better outcomes so if yeah
thank you for the question and that's a
good question yeah it is if you notice
the little boxes next to each provider
or facility name if you click on that
you can click on several and there's a
box on on the left box you can see
compare selected a lightly shaded box
that says yeah selected when you do that
those facilities pop up in all of their
quality scores for different
pre-selected parameters come up okay
great sorry I'm married to a doctor so
yeah okay thank you and those those are
a product of patient satisfaction
reports for pre-selected parameters yeah
okay look overall and keep in mind the
information on the next slide
yes higher cost care oftentimes does not
confer with better quality care so
research finds that there is no
relationship for this for example some
services like lab tests there's little
difference in quality no matter where
you go however as we saw in the last
slide there is still big differences in
cost
so now I'd like to talk about some of
our future goals for the New Hampshire
chis currently hospitals and carriers
are now under federal law required to
post the in-network and out of network
in uninsured rates on their websites New
Hampshire chis can be used to reconcile
that the actual claims data match the
price that providers or carriers list
for any given procedure
this serves as a great consumer
protection mechanism
and is indeed a price transparency
mechanism that is known to promote
competition exert downward pressure on
prices
and reveal disparities in discriminatory
pricing practices all of which are good
for New Hampshire consumers
I'd like to drill down to two specific
Innovations in price transparency the
hospital price transparency law requires
hospitals to post in-network out of
network in uninsured rates in a machine
readable file and a consumer friendly
format
whereas the transparency and coverage
legislation which applies to carriers
requires them to post negotiated rates
and cost-sharing information in a
consumer-friendly format
as well as post in-network provided
negotiated rates historical
out-of-network allowed amounts and Drug
pricing information through three
machine readable files posted on their
internet website
ultimately the goal is to get
these entities to post up to 500
shoppable services and a list can be
found listed below
lastly I'd like to point out evidence of
the effect or impact on prices
as a result from New Hampshire Health
cost
a paper that's available to you here and
we provided provided it to some of you
demonstrates that in the long run an 11
reduction in patients out-of-pocket
amount was observed as a result of
Services posted on New Hampshire Health
costs
this was seen on the supply side of the
market
long run reductions in prices on the
supply side can sometimes be referred to
as the Sentinel effect an example of
this is providers
observing each other and consequently
changing their pricing behaviors
additionally New Hampshire Health costs
and Price shopping in general can also
influence the demand side of the market
and as an example Shoppers Price
shopping and seeking out lower cost
Services is an example of demand side
effects
so I'm just curious
um I mean we all we all know that prices
have been going up so are they actually
going down or have the prices that when
you're siding here of these prices just
been moving up at a slower rate than I
don't know the General Medical inflation
rate like how do you measure that are
they actually falling in real terms
relative prices so the the price that a
patient would seek for any given service
is going down if
if that service was posted on health
costs so the way that it was modeled in
this paper I think you'd find this
interesting the way it was modeled in
this paper is if if a procedure got
posted to health cost within the next
four years the average reduction in
patient cost burden was down by 11
compared to
its counterpart if it did not get posted
on health costs it was an empirical
model that shows the effect of making
these prices transparent to the patient
to the consumer that if we make them
transparent it would exert a downward
pressure that in the long run would have
substantial
implications on price reduction you said
that there's a paper right there right
there's a paper all right cool I'll grab
that and read it thanks okay let's go
ahead but and if you have a few days
where you don't have anything to do
you're going to enjoy that region ah
thanks but let me just test them out
sure
uh let me just mention that
um you know in this paper they
identified two driving factors this is
what we're saying
um that in two ways in which health
costs has reduced prices one is by
influencing the supply side the provider
of services and that's where we make
reference to the Sentinel effect which
which which means sort of you don't need
that much actual shopping for the
providers to react on on their own and
anticipate uh and compare themselves to
other providers and respond with the
change in pricing so that's sort of the
way
transparency can have an effect on the
supply side and then on the demand side
it's simpler it's like consumer shopping
for the lowest cost MRI and actually
saving money
collabra has a question
I understand
um
we're looking at Health costs but having
been in dway for for Harbor care what
are the parameters other than patient
feedback are you getting to measure that
quality assurance
that that is um I'd like you to explore
that so you can see that the number of
um parameters that are listed under the
the quality of care but they they all
are patient uh satisfaction
qualitative surveys that are used to
inform that
we're we're constantly looking for ways
to improve the quality measures that we
use and
um you know the Precision of our price
measures and we we seek to do that in
many different ways
yeah
yeah all right well my last time I
checked this and it's been a while but
there was outcomes reporting outcomes
but it did seem you know I know I was
looking at my hospital for a particular
procedure and didn't have such a great
outcome and my concern was that because
it's a smaller hospital it doesn't have
as many procedures so your apt to uh you
know the one bad out one bad event can
skew the numbers
that's still true that's still being
reported those that's always true in all
statistics the a low frequency of any
parameter so a low frequency of
procedures
can bias results so Mike can I still see
that outcomes on on your web page so I
do you still have that yeah the outcomes
are qualitative in nature self-reported
qualitative right
okay
yes representative spear
good morning the database appears to be
pretty impressively extensive
but as you know we've been hearing bills
regarding drug prices as well as health
care
and you mentioned that you and in here
you talk about the fact that you have
drug prices
what I'm wondering is is the details as
to what went into that drug price there
like the wholesale cost the PBM prices
the kind of money they take in versus
the money they take out all that sort of
stuff is that available
thank you for the question another great
question so New Hampshire chess which is
the data used to power Health costs uses
empirical medical claims data so none of
that market data is available in the
chis nor expressed in New Hampshire
Health cost
representative Gibbs thank you
um I'm going to phrase this as kindly as
I can
um
could you tell us
um why um when I tried to test the
public facing
database where members of the public
could check costs of certain procedures
at hospitals
the results seem to bear
almost no relationship to reality and
I'll tell you very briefly what I based
that question on it was uh based on on a
procedure that I had myself in August of
2021 in Concord Hospital
um and the bill which I got because
Medicare and Blue Cross couldn't agree
as to who was responsible and eventually
they sent the bill to me
um the bill I got was for thirty seven
thousand dollars
um the procedure was referred to by my
doctor as repair of a hiatal hernia so I
tried to find that procedure in the
insurance Department's system couldn't
find that found the closest thing that I
could and the prices ranged from
something under ten thousand dollars to
something around twenty one thousand
dollars as I said
um the actual bill that I got was for
thirty seven thousand dollars so again
my question is why did the results
um bear so little relationship to
reality
thank you and that was a very kind way
to ask that question so
um
identifying prices for an encounter at a
healthcare provider or even just a a
doctor's visit is inherently difficult
there are a lot of other ancillary
services that are involved with it and
various case mix intensity or patient
complexity to those services and
providers are well aware of this they've
communicated that to us and it's one of
the biggest challenges with gleaning
precision and accuracy in these types of
websites our colleagues in Maine have a
very similar website and suffer some of
the same anguish
a not so kind questions
um with their legislature too and so we
look to narrow that down but it's a good
question I think it's important to
understand what health cost is and what
is not it's not
um similar to a price tag in a retail
setting where you can just look at a
price tag and understand what the what
the absolute price for that product or
service is rather it's a way to get a
sense for how much a certain medical
intervention or medical procedure might
cost you there are a lot of factors that
affect the variation in the the delivery
of those estimates and that was primary
purpose for us coming here is to help
you to better understand what what it is
what it does what the source of the data
that informs those price estimates are
and so you can be more informed to make
some of these important Health policy
decisions that lie in front of you
and um you know also one of the
challenges is determining
um the shoppable services that we're
going to list so here your procedure
wasn't listed on our site we have some
250 now
and the federal law on transparency it
aims at 500 shoppable Services
even if you're up at 500 it's going to
sometimes be difficult to find that
service on the website that matches well
with you know what your own experience
is
foreign
what is the approximate number of sight
hits that you get per year to the uh to
your website
so um I listened to here 250 000 I think
it was last year that that we recorded
over 250 000 yeah
yeah um so in terms of legislation that
we have in front of us we have the one
that uh related to that Federal postings
and you have here a.gov listing here
and then they were saying that some
hospitals weren't compliance so they
were not using this particular list this
with the government the federal
government list is
I'm trying to figure where it was
their CMS list their list of 500 shops
yeah so I assume all our hospitals are
on this list or I mean that legislation
which said if they didn't post then they
did they get it for free I just wondered
whether it have you do you guys look at
this list and make sure all our
hospitals are on there and we uh what
we're doing we have assumed
responsibility for enforcement of the
um part of the federal legislation that
governs Health carriers so there's that
rule called transparency and coverage
and we've responded to the federal
government that we are assuming
responsibility for enforcing the posting
of of
those prices we do not have
responsibility for hospitals uh pricing
although we have plans for using that
information to supplement Health costs
okay
supplement okay
all right
you need a mic but there's a different
enforcement uh entity not the insurance
department
so there is a federal enforcement yeah
yeah okay we'll we'll get to that that
issue yes representative Ammon
thank you um
does New Hampshire Health costs provide
machine readable uh files if if you're
assuming responsibility for the carriers
that's one of the requirements I read
here
no that's that's for carriers to post on
their website and so that's not on New
Hampshire Health cost
and just follow questions but for the
question
are there as the data comes in are there
any like quality uh checks to see if
something is out of uh you know out of
the norm and that it could yeah so we've
been working with we've been working
with CMS and they have a validator tool
that is used to validate the Fidelity of
the submissions and so we're planning to
be using that to
confirm that they're in material
compliance with their submission of that
those data that's where the the new uh
Federal requirements for professional
transparency but we also contract with
an entity under for our own all player
claims database to do a validity check
on the claims data that we get from the
carriers and that just happens routinely
okay so then
to the sidebar to this is now oh
represent I'm sorry I didn't see your
hand up representative Walsh thank you
how often do you update your data is it
daily weekly like to add procedures or
to add prescription drugs I want to make
it clear that shiz data gets updated we
get quarterly uploads from our vendor
for the chiz data and then we just did
on Monday the quarterly Refresh on New
Hampshire Health cost generally every
quarter we add somewhere between 15 to
18 new codes new procedures on onto
Health costs so that number the number
of services listed there keeps growing
and so you won't find all procedures
in the CPT code book which there's tens
of thousands you won't find those On Any
Price shopping website for the question
thank you so your
relegated to CMS so you can't do
anything other than in a three-month
period
you said it comes in quarterly that's
just our process
because medical claims sometimes there's
a there's a latency to the development
of one medical claim it can sometimes
take weeks even months for one service
to fully go through a claims process so
the probably the shortest tenure for
that would be a quarter if you made it
monthly you would have fragmented claims
coming in so how we process our medical
claims and get them into one database is
that's done right maybe I'm not saying
this correctly I'm not talking about the
claims I'm talking about adding
procedures you know the list of your
procedures in the list I mean I realize
they're integrated with claims but just
to add like a new procedure yeah so
given that we use the medical claims
database to inform that that process too
it's relegated to taking on the same
timing because there there's an
exhaustive process that we use to go
through and identify these 15 to 18
procedures they have to be price stable
there has to be a sufficient frequency
of them they they have to be as um
there's a contextual part they have to
be a public health interest right so
they have there has to be certain set of
criteria that are quite objective
actually that we use to ascertain with
our existing data as it stands what
makes the grade what gets there I do
understand representative Gibbs
frustrations about not being able to
find your procedure or or sufficiently
precise cost estimates for it but in
this absence would be guessing we'd have
nothing to refer to to identify what
might be some of the approximate costs
for this procedure that I'm about to
decide on or or endure so three three
months is generally
a short period of time for for that to
evolve into something that's utilizable
and something that we do our due
diligence to make sure that we have as
price as precise as possible estimates
and and it's not always
um sufficient but
it's necessary
representative purselli
we've been discussing
prescription drugs a lot so do you have
I'll try to put all my questions in one
do you have a site or a navigation to
your site so we could look at pers
changes in prescription drugs or costs
and is it possible to collect the data
that we're looking for related to
wholesale retail and are you
collaborating with any other entities
like UNH that seems to also be
collecting this data so in in the chis
data there are many variables for price
prices of prescription drugs that's
included in the prescription drug file
but there's also a robust set of data in
the medical claims file for this these
new classes of specialty drugs that are
delivered in medical settings
so those exist there right now on health
costs we pulled the prescription drug
estimates off because of for that very
reason of price instability because
they're wildly variable across service
types and providers and that so because
it didn't meet our criteria for putting
a stable price estimate up there
right we have criteria first price
stability and it would we found it
to be the more responsible decision yet
a difficult one because that for as an
example is a public health interest and
it's OB it's of legislative interest too
so nobody more than us would like to
have robust data on health costs for
prescription drugs but because of the
price instability we it's it's suspend
is taken off from there right now
yeah it's a good question
foreign
my the second part of my question was
collaboration with other entities that
are trying to collect this data and I I
I don't really understand about the pers
the prescription drug costs so I think
that would be
very informative to people that wanted
to check their thank you and I
wholeheartedly agree with you it's it's
probably the most pressing public health
issue in in our work right now that we'd
like to help better inform legislative
bodies on there there are multiple
complexities to that and we
we do collaborate with with other
entities and our that process is ongoing
yes
thank you so
oh okay representative Terry
thank you did you want to ask your
question first I'll wait oh thank you
uh so I I'm still back on representative
gibbs's question and I'm wondering about
the Practical value to Consumers
when I hear representative Gibson if I'm
incorrect please
refresh my memory that you went on the
site and you saw a range of 10 to 21
000 dollars
for a hiatal hernia repair
they didn't actually have the procedure
so
all right so and then I heard you say
that it actually cost you thirty seven
thousand dollars
so if you would would be willing to take
this on as a case study to help us
better understand how
a consumer goes to the sites he's 10 to
000 then ends up with a bill of thirty
seven thousand dollars I I have heard
you indicate that well there are other
ancillary or Supportive Services that
may go into the thirty seven thousand
which once again brings explanatory
value to the difference between the
range of 10 to 21 and 37 but then
reverts to my initial question which is
of what practical benefit in the final
analysis is a search for a particular
procedure when the range is 10 to 21 and
it ends up costing 37. there needs to be
some explanation here drilling down and
exposing the difference between the 10
to 21 and the 37. yes yes could you
could you respond to that please so yeah
it's one of the biggest challenges in
bundling a package of health care
services for example
a hiatal the surgery for a hiatal hernia
is in a hospital and presumably a
hospital stay is involved so right there
you have facility charges that can range
from one day to seven days or even more
and so that's one not trivial example of
yes variable yeah variable and I think
it's
a much damage yeah
foreign
okay you have to talk to Mike
unfortunately she's had hearing issues
Al can say it okay I have a little more
relevance would you want to say how many
days you were in the hospital that day
for this procedure
okay uh this was this was the problem
I stayed overnight but technically it
was outpatient surgery that's why Blue
Cross and Medicare couldn't agree on who
was responsible for paying it so I
stayed overnight but technically it was
outpatient surgery I can't so hence the
extra 10 grand is that you stayed
overnight excuse me
the extra 10 grand was that did you
stayed overnight yeah
theoretically
no reduced date overnight so the
hospital billed for that extra night the
insurance company says the outpatient I
don't think that was it that that at
least according to what they said they
said it was outpatient surgery even
though
I was there I actually stayed overnight
outpatient surgery is as what they
expected to be no but that no it was it
was all planned in advance
that you were going to say overnight yes
but because under the billing codes or
whatever the there's not something I can
explain under under their system
outpatient search surgery even though
everybody knew
from the get-go that I was going to stay
overnight got it representative Terry
has another comments
did you want to finish or I just wanted
to repeat the questioner's point
um because he wasn't able to be near the
microphone but yes his point was that
the uh most important factor here is
that
um the
procedure that representative Gibbs
underwent was not
any procedure that was listed on health
costs she had to look at something that
she determined to be similar but
um that's not a reliable methodology in
order to be confident about what's
posted on health costs you have to
actually have that procedure or bundle
of procedures
follow-up question
so which one should go first the one who
still has been doing this yielded to
represent I know let's see what trouble
that gets here
okay because she once you give her the
mic he ain't gonna give it up lately
okay now representative Terry
thank you
so uh
so if the range is 10 to 21
and the patient's experience is 37. what
I'm hearing is that there are a variety
of factors there are variables so you
you can't you can't as you said in your
initial testimony you can't put a retail
price on something like if you want to
go buy a book on Amazon so there are a
variety of factors and we understand
that because this is a this is a health
care a complicated Health Care procedure
might involve a number of days uh uh
certain types of anesthesia certain
other kinds of ancillary services in
order to to treat the patient all right
understand so if if this is the case do
you provide a disclaimer I've never
visited the site because I've never had
to do this a disclaimer that indicates
this is a this is a in effect a rough
estimate a range uh and a rough estimate
your actual costs may not in actuality
are likely to be significant
significantly different than this range
because of a multiplicity of factors
such as yada yada yada yada otherwise
back to my initial question is and that
is how is this ever going to be
meaningful to a consumer when there are
these multiple factors involved that can
skew the the range of 10 to 21 to as
much as 37.
you're trying to help consumers here who
who want to find Reliable information
is there a disclaimer is there not and
would it be helpful if there was because
that's effectively what I'm hearing that
because there are all these other
factors
the consumer needs to know that it could
be a lot more than that
thank you and the commissioner would
like to I think I think that's a point
and we talked earlier about uh how how
reliable the estimate was and so for
some of those factors we have a lot of
billing events we're going to have a
very reliable number and that range is
going to be narrower for Unique services
that there aren't as many occurrences
the range or where the Acuity is more
severe the range is going to be bigger
and you're not going to have the same
reliability and that's some of the
things that we balance when we're
looking at what services to add to
health cost is we want to put services
on that have the best value to or or the
best use to consumers in New Hampshire
reliability reliability thank you
okay now representative Gibbs
thank you
um first of all I want to thank
representative Terry who very clearly
articulated the point of my original
question
um and
then my question to you is
um
considering that
it appeared my surgery was not a
particularly uncommon type of surgery uh
because my doctor was very experienced
in it and had a whole robotic system set
up for doing that particular type of
surgery
why wasn't it on your system
so one of one of the criteria we use to
ascertain should this service be listed
on health costs is the frequency of that
procedure so
not all procedures are on there we
generally put them through a litmus test
we identify about 100 to 120 procedures
each quarter and then do descriptive
analyzes on them we analyze how
frequently have they occurred how common
were the set of codes service codes
across all encounters
how consistent are the bundles is what
I'm trying to say for that and what's
the price stability and if they don't
meet that criteria we don't add them to
health costs so the ones that you see
reflected on health costs have met that
criteria their their
produced at a certain amount of
frequency they're very common in terms
of the conventions used to bundle them
and there's price stability and and so
it can be frustrating
um to look for this procedure that
you're going to have done and not have
it there and wonder and call into
question the utility of it and we have
those frustrations too but at the same
time we do a lot of background work to
do our due diligence to make sure that
the estimates that get up there have at
least some homogeneity to them they're
similar in price and they have frequency
they're stable compared to others so
before I take another question but would
wouldn't it be possible that you would
do a range to have the high and low also
listed
the worst case scenario in the best case
scenario that even though you say this
is our average our statistical mean
average or whatever you want to call it
but that you say but by the way this you
know there's a potential this procedure
could cost x amount you know the high
versus the low and obviously in the the
examples that I use what you do see a
range that's a range of the procedures
that have made it onto Health costs
these other procedures that have not
been stable to make it to health costs
their ranges are a much more variable we
use a measure that I I was reluctant to
get into more statistical jargon but
I'll talk to you right it's called
kurtosis it's how narrow the range is so
we use kurtosis as the primary measure
to ascertain whether or not it's going
to be on there something that has a
really wide range it's just not stable
enough yeah but it exists yes that
that's all I'm saying is that it um
again I'm not an expert on statistics
but that if you had your mean and you
have your average but then you would say
the worst case scenario this is how high
that number was yes and the best case
scenario this is how low it was not
saying that people did but at least then
someone can say is see their number
somewhere near that high then let's say
okay so I obviously there was more to it
with my particular situation
yeah
something to consider would you believe
this wasn't a question it was more or
less speaking directly to representative
Gibbs and trying to help expedite this
little part
um your procedure is really rare it's
not something that happens very often
and so having that kind of measurable
data in a database is just not going to
happen
fair enough there are a lot of things
okay representative
it's someone related to that what is the
minimum end that to even be listed on
the database
it's expressed in this coefficient of
variation I didn't want to get get into
the statistics right it's it's
expressing the coefficient of variation
so how you measure that is the very the
standard deviation divided by
the square root of the N so that's how
it inputs into that and so the the more
widely variable ones are inherently
imposed to lower frequency of procedures
great but do you have a do you have a
minimum to even be to be uh triggered to
be on the database I think it's 30.
so is it is it possible then that you
may have some procedures that are so
rare as to not even be listed on the
database and therefore a consumer is
going looking for it would not find what
they're looking for yeah that's why
we're proud of this new federal
legislation because they can get that
information now from hospital providers
and the carriers with these new
transparency and care
laws one more follow-up okay but would
you say it's accurate that your database
is more of a guide to a consumer rather
than being prescriptive to a consumer as
to what their cost is going to be yes
this extensive
um language on the website
describing how the methodology that we
use if you've seen if you've seen that
you would answer a lot of questions but
also the limitations of interpretation
of the price estimates that you get that
this is just a range a suggestion for a
more precise estimate call your provider
or your insurance company and we we
emphasize that language
I still think you should put the high
and low in yeah yeah just just so so
when someone because most people aren't
going to look they just look at the
number and you know so but at any rate
representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair I just want to say I
appreciate your presentation and I I
being a database person I understand the
challenges involved with taking this
disparate data and trying to make it
consumer friendly and what I'm hearing
is that over time this system is going
to improve we're going to have more and
more transparency and then that will
have a benefit to the marketplace and
the consumer so thank you for trying to
explain this to us thank you I
appreciate you too okay
thank you this is going to lead into our
next subcommittee this question but do
you feel that there's added value to the
uh prescription drug affordability board
to the Chris database
we don't have a position or not I think
to the extent that uh put the mic on
your the department has no position on
the pdap board uh we're fortunate that
Jason was appointed by the governor as a
alternate member of the board uh
obviously our position on getting
information out to New Hampshire
consumers is critical I think good data
that people can use is helpful
um some of the you know how how we
deliver that and how that information
gets out to folks that's for you to
decide
okay well then I want to follow up on
that and that is
um given that we have a statutory
requirement of the MRA if I got to write
the the 10 what do we what is that is it
called MRA
mlr okay so this is really important for
everybody this was passed on the
Affordable Care Act or Obamacare
whichever you want to call it
um and that is that is limited a uh in
terms of premiums that it limited uh the
premium setting it's a three-year look
back a three-year average of What uh the
medical costs that an insurance company
incurs so that means all the
pharmaceutical bills and all the doctors
and hospitals and everything is all
compiled and then they cannot charge
more than 10 percent over that number
for that premium so that means in that
10 it's going to be their profit it's
going to be their uh advertising costs
and operating costs and all that stuff
it's got to fit into that ten percent so
the reason what I'm asking is so when it
comes to this affordable uh you guys
actually do know exactly how much a
pharmaceutical costs and you do see all
the rebates and all the Kickbacks and
all that money that's going back and
forth so that when you determine the MRA
you really are getting a good number
um I so mlr mlr and I think it's
typically 15 or 17 not 10. I thought it
was 10 and 15. the record there
um and I I think we would see final
digit numbers I can't say for certain
that we at the department get to see
um total rebate dollars for prescription
drugs
I don't I don't think so how would you
be able to who does the mlr then well
we're doing it on on Total Medical spend
across their their whole book whether or
not they're using a PBM
um and what that actual cost is
um
though you're not you know obviously
we're talking be hundreds of millions of
lines of data if you were looking at
every rebate for every prescription drug
so so the question is could there be uh
something that's going on outside so
that the mlr is not truly reflecting how
much it's costing that insurance company
for pharmaceuticals
no I don't if I understand your question
uh if the true cost of pharmaceuticals
is factored into the mlr and that true
Factor includes
rebates and coupons and everything I'm
not saying that nobody's ever messed
that up because they have they're
complicated formulas but it should be
completely represented right and and
therefore when you set your pricing that
you're you're looking at all those
things are you looking at just the I
mean I guess the whole purpose of this
this pharmaceutical affordable was that
the assumption that there's some funny
money going on behind the scenes okay
well maybe I misunderstood that I
thought the whole purpose of pdab was so
that the board could give some direction
to the state payers for what they should
Target for their prescription drugs
um no the purpose was that the
Assumption the Assumption of that board
is that there is something funny going
on behind the scenes and they want to
know what it is and that way they can
suggest that we would pass legislation
to stop it
maybe we should move on to 172. yeah
okay
is it representative spear
thank you for giving up
my understanding based on what you've
been saying is yes in fact you do know
the total price of drugs and you can say
that this drug costs this amount of
money and that's what the insurance
company paid for it or didn't pay for it
I'll cover for it
I think but the pdab is trying to do is
go below that much more into the details
of who's getting paid for what because
if as we've been hearing is is a lot of
uh
interaction between the wholesalers the
people the pbms and the insurance
companies and feedbacks going back and
forth and everything but I didn't get
the impression from what you were saying
that those level of details were in
there that you were talking more about
the total cost of the drug
is that true I don't believe we get data
for our rebates we get we get wholesale
cost and then ultimately their analysis
done for mlr which is total Med spend
so that's a total
so you can't test it by looking at your
numbers ah well I can't extrapolate from
that right if or not there's a rebate or
not okay but we
get the total okay representative
Burrows I had nothing to say Oh I
thought you okay all right we all set
thank you very much gentlemen thank you
okay now let's go into our
subcommittee
um
all right brief recess
thank you
okay
all right okay let everybody take their
seats please
yes we're having loads of fun
all right
so we'll start out with House Bill 172
relative investigating potential
redundancies between the prescription
drug affordably board and existing state
aging programs
regarding prescription drug cost data so
I just spoke to the uh
not to sponsor the anti-sponsor the
opposite side and uh um I agreed that uh
we'll just retain this so that we can
understand better what's what the intent
of the bill is since maybe we don't have
the same perception but I I want to go
on record that
um I would just assume uh I if I were to
pass something I would have uh just
assumed to remove the assessments on
these companies on the insurance
companies in particular because it it
seems an oxymoron to me that if we're
trying to lower our health insurance
costs why would we then be adding a new
tax onto insurance companies
um having said that uh the
um
the the uh and and that where the I
would say that if they need money they
should go to finance it should be in the
governor's budget you know but uh I
guess maybe Tom Tom you know the
governor doesn't answer your phone calls
Maybe
okay
maybe that happened so but be acutely
aware of that maybe that might be some
some uh past uh issues there but but
um but I I also I have to admit I was a
little shocked that AARP is coming in in
support of this bill and supporting this
commission when they're the ones who own
their own insurance company they have
their own insurance product so you would
think that AARP could get all that
information that so-called black box
from just calling up U.S Healthcare
their their provider so uh but
notwithstanding that uh I know that the
legislation was originally initiated by
new Futures and uh and I know that
they're a private foundation with Oodles
of money
um and so therefore I think that that if
they really want to do this in partially
those two entities should help fund or
they can go out to other funds so I
haven't limited just simply to remove
the money and to uh just have that the
money go through Finance you know if
we're going to do appropriation
otherwise create a fund so that people
can make donations to it
notwithstanding um I've agreed to retain
this bill but I just want you to know
that's where I'm thinking about when we
get to it next time next spring do we
not need a vote from the subcommittee on
whether to retain yes yes I'm
recommending okay because you said I'm
retaining so no I'm sorry
in the very old days when retaining was
originally created
when they're when the retaining was
originally created the chair
could just unilaterally say from the
sense of the conversation and where I
think we are that retaining but
obviously there would have to be a
conversation you can't just say I have a
sense you know I just pull a sentence
I'm not that sensitive no right but
um so I if it sounds like I'm I'm uh
dictating the retaining no I'm assuming
that um everyone would be
um comfortable with a retaining option
do you want to ask if there's any
discussion from anybody oh yeah no I
haven't made any motion yet okay you're
not there you even made the motion yet
we haven't we haven't haven't I don't
even know if I had the subcommittee
worksheets
who has the subcommittee worksheet Terry
okay you have the subcommittee worksheet
I I sometimes
I see it okay
all right so
um the subcommittee is uh representative
Terry post purcelli hunt collabro
Vincent Sullivan and Burroughs
that's the old list okay
I thought I had a pen oh here it is I
have a pen I got a pen
okay so on this one Vincent is no longer
on it
right
yeah
and Gibbs is I thought oh
Sullivan is no longer on it Gibbs
replaced
okay that's right that's right
okay am I all am I all correct in the
red is everybody else the correct list
it was just that those two that I
switched okay I gotta talk to Carrie
about that okay
so
um
I I I moved to uh retain
and do I hear a second for routine uh
okay
any discussion on the retained motion
hopefully I can still do parliamentary
process problems okay I see no
discussion on the uh retained motion so
all those in favor just raise your hand
one two three four five six seven okay
pass seven zip
okay
moving right along all right relative to
insurance coverage for pain management
surfaces
and so I'm now Crossing out Sullivan and
his name is Gibbs
okay
this is the one that's got every
everything under the sun
right
people
today
so
given a lot of insurance companies
actually do cover some of these things
um and a and b that for us to cover
things why don't you do that you must
have a mouth in your bag
and given that we have
um
some things here that don't even have
credentialing
yoga has credentialing
right well I used to I used to say that
um I mean I'll I go back to uh it was
laidak licensed alcohol and drug that
they first they went one year they went
to Edna
to get licensed
right because it was they were a new
thing there was it's a new kind of
mental health that came out of nowhere
and so they went there and got licensed
and then the following year they came
here
for us to give them third-party
insurance reimbursement and I said so so
I go to the Edna say don't license these
people because they'll be running up to
Congress the following year
so the question is is is there really
anything we can do that with this bill
it is a health insurance mandate which
generally most of us are are a little uh
you know that's adding more Health costs
amount I mean I think one point in time
um Tyler Brennan who's no longer here
with insurance you know but he he said
it was about five percent mandates
five mandates were about five percent of
the health insurance costs which is you
know in the scheme of things not much
um and certainly not as as compared to
Pharmaceuticals as they are now but that
the idea of adding uh going through this
when the marketplace seems to be picking
these things up so representative spear
I
I took the most there is something there
are some insurance companies now that
covers acupuncture yeah but it's it's a
very limited basis and for instance if
you're on Medicare you can only get it
for back injury there's only a couple of
things you can get it from appreciate
you bringing that up so remember when we
do these health insurance mandates
we're only covering about a third of the
state's population okay because anybody
who is on Medicare or Medicaid or an
erisa self you know employer provided
package they are exempt but John what a
lot of companies do is they if Medicare
only covers
for back that's all I'm gonna do
um so uh having sat on this seat
longer than I probably should have
bought it right
um I would say that I have it's an
interesting Trend what happens with
companies and one of the big companies
that I really follow is the state
employees
and I'll never forget when we had we
passed the um coverage for family
members of who were under 26.
and and used to be the law used to be
that insurance companies would keep them
on as long as they were in a full-time
Academic Program
and then there was some like if you go
to beauty school that wasn't included
and that you know we so we got to push
back on that so when we ended up passing
that that meant they get passed but the
state employees didn't they didn't have
it so I would hear every time I would
hear somebody complaining about it I
knew exactly that they were where they
were coming from because that was one of
the few entities but eventually once uh
the Affordable Care Act was passed that
now is across the board
um and and and covers even erises erises
can be very creative
um small employer I mean a large
employers or risks they can be very
creative in doing different programs and
but that again that's usually Union
generated if they're have a union job or
it's generated from that they really
want to do that for their employees so
um but again that we we don't regulate
that rises are federally regulated so
that in general we try to very limit the
amount of things we do in this bill if
you look at the way the bill is written
and I'm not looking at it but I'm sure
it's going to be in different sections
of the law so you a you it's the small
group market and then it's the non-group
or what we call the individual Market
the marketplace as we know it today so
um that that would be the the next
paragraph that these are the different
paragraphs it would cover so my I I'd
say at this point
I mean we could retain it and talk about
and say is there something we want to
pick and choose but
um I'm I'm not sold on that that in the
insurance company won't offer it if if
there seems to be a demand or want
desire for it representative Terry so
having heard your recommendation Mr
chairman or your suggested
recommendation
um one of the things that I have
mentioned to colleagues when they've
asked us about our committee process is
that when we get to the subcommittee
level and they hear what the feedback is
from the committee that they would have
an opportunity to uh to respond to that
not argument scores to appeal I'm
wondering if representative I believe
representative Nagel is here I wonder if
he has any thoughts on base on what he
is so please come up to the mic because
I I'm sort of after having talked with
him I'm sort of inclined in being
favorably disposed not necessarily to to
uh to favor the bill but to retain it
retain it for further information so
thank you very much
thank you representative Terry thank you
chairman hunt
um
you pretty much took the words out of my
mouth there is a parallel bill
um that we're seeing in Health and Human
Services to create a committee to um
discuss this bill in Greater detail
we've met with the insurance
Representatives we've met with all the
providers that are involved in this
issue we acknowledge that there's some
issues with this bill but we think that
as a group we can work on it together
therefore we would like to retain that
proceed in that way and then get back to
you
yep representative Calabro I wanted to
move to retain it I was talking with Dr
Neagle and the elements that were
problematic I think can be ironed out
okay so great thank you so is there
anybody else in the audience who uh
thinks differently about retaining
okay I always have to ask that question
okay so uh uh representative Calabro
seconded by representative Terry moose
uh to retain
any discussion on the motion
yes representative
okay so uh retaining bills means that we
will be discussing him in the fall
and that we would have to have this out
of committee uh the last week of August
I mean October excuse me anybody have a
calendar you can see what the date is
but it's usually the end of last the end
of October and that means it will hit
the house floor
um uh the first week of January
so that's one week you don't want to
miss
because all the bills that were retained
will reappear that first week
yeah first because it's always funny
because Ed Butler would always take go
to New York that week and I said he said
why would you miss out on that week but
yeah so representative purcelli
if there is
[Music]
to study this
outcome from that committee to we would
be we would be interested in knowing
what happened so are they turning it
into a chapter study or are they what
are they planning on doing what kind of
a committee are they talk are they they
talking about
there's two kinds of committees or
there's what we said a is retaining an
interim an interim study is technically
a study committee but you're study we
keep it in the committee
you can do a chapter study
um and which generally the chapter
studies would include legislators House
and Senate members and we generally say
you don't want to do that the second
year because that would be campaign
season and nobody wants to show up and
the third thing is a commission study
commission and that way you get uh
participants from the different
um
the people it's people in constituency
would be be involved and they all have
input
um I always say that uh over my years
that uh study those commissions was the
best way to really make sure nothing
gets done because everybody's
everybody's got their own extra grind
and so so uh and and so over my years
I've only did that once and that was
over a privacy issue so some further
clarification the committee yes who is
the makeup of the committee
so what is it you guys already the
committee will have I'm sorry doc uh
representative Merchant is the reason
I'm the passion so
um he has all the details on that but
it's
um there were going to be two senators
three reps um we pretty much already
discussed who those people would be the
plan would be to meet this summer have
something to you by the fall right so
that's a chapter study committee so um
so theoretically their results wouldn't
come out until the same time where we
you know actually a chapter studies get
an extra month I think they can they
finally can report in December but
um so theoretically would be parallel to
that so we would be waiting to hear if
if there's anything came out of it and
then we would then could take it up in
our subcommittee with that said we're
all one happy family now so this will be
an ongoing discussion anyways
okay everybody all set
okay uh so that's Terry post purcelli
hunt collabro Vincent's not here and
Gibbs and Burrows so all those in favor
retaining please raise your hand
okay
seven zip
establishing a committee uh let's see
Bill number 319 establishing a committee
to study in all pair system insurance
for Hospital services
okay
I guess I need to go get my pills
I don't have I I don't understand uh so
who would like to start talking about
people
so is anybody here for this film
okay
uh
okay let me let me let me go I don't
have a problem
okay
Okay so
this is sort of like the Canadian model
is that what this is
okay we don't take testimony okay so
when we're going to invite you up is
when we in our discussion we had get to
a place where we need input so
you have to talk on the mic you have to
come up to the mic
right
now you gotta turn yeah red is good be
helpful if you could talk with uh I have
a newborn I'm taking care of so uh when
I'm not working so Bill 319
um is not in reference to
a Canadian Health System it's in
reference to what's being done in the
states of Maryland Pennsylvania and
looked at but actually Vermont in a
different way is in reference to what's
called an all-payer
health system which is very relevant to
the um what you've just heard testimony
from the insurance department
so by the way as a as a physician I've
been on the uh the New Hampshire Health
cost site
and I appreciate the efforts of the
insurance department
but what affects people's uh bankruptcy
and uh affordability are procedures the
only procedure mentioned
was an arthroscopy it doesn't mention
common procedures bypass surgery it
doesn't mention
other common procedures that are
extraordinary in cost
um you can go to a charge Master with
the insurance department was able to
provide you are you speaking to this
Bill yes this is relevant to this bill
so there's so I'll speed it along sorry
if you go to that Health site you'll see
huge discrepancies because what was not
mentioned this morning is private
insurers negotiate separately behind
closed doors for those costs that's why
I suppose this is on the Commerce
committee's lab
health care costs however
you're not consuming having a hiatal
hernia repair
like you consume an apple when you go to
the produce department at the at the
grocery
you are receiving Health Care
listening to the Commerce Committee
discuss
these matters is like putting a square
peg into a round hole it's bizarre
the efforts to try to incorporate all
the intricacies of health care costs
when you have private insurers who are
opaque to how they're negotiating costs
behind closed doors is bizarre it's
never going to happen but I appreciate
their efforts so what all-pair system
modeled on the Maryland model does
is it sets a single cost
for every hospital and
hospital-associated procedure
made by Medicaid
Medicare and every employer sponsored
Insurance there is one cost per Hospital
not every hospital will have the same
cost
Dartmouth which has a tertiary Care
Center a neonatal ICU has different
costs and demands than Cottage Hospital
20 miles away each Hospital
negotiates with
a New Hampshire agency typically run in
concert with the insurance department to
set a single transparent cost for every
one of those procedures that you folks
were trying to figure out this morning
that incentivizes doctors to take
Medicaid so it's not a third class
citizenship it incentivizes the
hospitals to take Medicaid where they'll
try to put these patients on the uh out
of the or so you're going to be paid
Higher by the insurance company for the
same knee replacement it incentivizes
primary care which is a lost leader how
does it incentivize it so the important
question thank you chair uh chairman
hunt
right now hospitals make their revenue
in which they sit on large revenues as
you all know non-profit hospitals I'm
talking about
make their revenue by seeking out those
procedures which give them the most
money that makes sense but they're
non-profit they're tax exempt so that's
why you see the advertisements for
getting your knee replaced you're hip
replaced having your bypass surgery
there those are big bucks because they
negotiate far above what Medicare pays
for those procedures
on the other hand those same hospitals
that have bought out Primary Care
practices
those Primary Care practices get paid
what Medicare provides 10 percent more
at maximum so they have no incentive to
have you go to see your doctor to
discuss your high cholesterol or manage
your diabetes or help you motivate to
quit smoking so you don't need your
bypass surgery
because they make more money off the
bypass surgery it is a lost leader this
is the intricacy of Health Care why it's
before the Commerce Committee is is
you're going to answer my question how
no I just answered it so I'll answer it
again hospitals are incentivized to make
Revenue off of high paying procedures
today you're saying that's what's going
on now that is the current reality how
does this bill incentivize hospitals to
be cheaper by by oh so that's really
important number one it sets a price
for that it helps negotiate what the
prices for Cottage Hospital Littleton
Southern New Hampshire if there's an
agency that works with the insurance
companies the private insurance
companies works with Medicaid works with
Medicare and sets a uniform price for
that hospital which is lower in in
average to what they are getting paid by
the employee sponsored insurances it
lowers your premiums by the way it
lowers your deductibles the data is
clear how does it do it go to the total
cost of care in Maryland site it's easy
to do it's on a website they saved
Medicare alone 1.2 billion dollars this
is in billions of dollars how does it do
it it's set by lowering the cost overall
to a uniform Level Playing Field
Medicaid so at the end of the day the
hospital cost is going to get lowered
price of the service by the hospital to
all insurers is identical whether you're
a Medicaid Medicare or employee and it
is an average number no way in my mind
that they could be used well you should
Medicaid because I'm my understanding no
no it raises the price to Medicaid which
is why hospitals are interested that
means raise the cost to the state
go ahead you have a question no that's
not true it lowers the price of the
state wait a minute wait a minute okay
how can that be you can't be both
yes representative question well no uh
well I appreciate the colloquy uh in
which you are engaged with the the man
who's testifying the doctor
um but I believe that the the bill
establishes a committee to study an
all-payer system that's correct your
initial question is Iraq call Mr
chairman was was this a Canadian model
in the response at the beginning of the
of the uh testimony or the response to
the question since we're not in formal
testimony today was no this is modeled
after State systems such as the Maryland
system or the Pennsylvania system you
have to have anybody from Maryland so my
understanding is you know not so much
here today to debate the merits of an
all-payer system as to whether or not we
even want to bother to have it studied
as to its applicability
um here in the state of New Hampshire
I'm clear on that that's correct this is
just this study and so if that's the
question then I would have a question if
I may
um who are the police refresh my memory
who are the constituent members of the
study committee who appoints them and
when is the report done okay I have that
list thank you I have the Commissioner
of Health and Human Services or a
designee the insurance commissioner or
designee a physician and member of New
Hampshire Medical Society appointed by
the society it represented the New
Hampshire Hospital Association appointed
by the Association one or more
representatives of organizations
responsible for reimbursement of Health
Care such as Medicaid chip Federal State
charitable or private agencies as
appointed by the governor a New
Hampshire Health policy advisor who has
experts teas in the Maryland all payer
total cost of care model and other state
all-pair systems appointed by the
governor and chairman respectfully the
first part of the membership of the of
the committee includes four members of
the House of Representatives appointed
by the Speaker of the House one member
of the Senate appointed by the president
of the senate members of the committee
to receive mileage and so basically and
then the Commissioner of Health yeah
just so you know why I did that okay
remember I started out with a study
committee would be just legislators and
Senate a commission
which is this doesn't say a commission
but that's what it is okay because it
then has the whole Myriad of interested
parties in there
well these are these are no no but these
are folks to be called upon for
information the committee is a is a uh
we shall solicit the information and
testimony from these people correct I
gotcha I did not see that do we have a
due date for the report the due date
would probably be the end of the uh
November uh due days November 1st so
it's my understanding that essentially
you'd be studying the Maryland system
the Pennsylvania system whatever and and
whether or not it would have uh any
favorable applicability to the unique
state that we are in distinction we have
similarities but differences with
respect to those two states that I just
cited correct and not to engage in
caliloquy but I do think it's worthwhile
pointing out that we have pricing
failures in this aspect of Health Care
your premiums may go down a little bit
next year because of covid but the
insurance commission has an annual
report of the cost of premiums in New
Hampshire and the cost of deductibles
that is you pay
twenty thousand dollars a year to get
your health insurance but then you have
to pay five thousand dollars to pay for
that procedure that you've just paid so
there's an ex a pricing failure that is
due to the opaqueness of this
negotiations between pbms as well as
hospitals and and private insurers all
uh the price is actually determined by
this uh and and as well taken this will
be studied but the reason prices go down
is they are set lower than what they are
currently that is but satisfies the
insurers who are not objectionable to
this in Maryland nor the hospitals who
are not objecting to this in Maryland in
fact they had protection during covid
when they had their Global budgets
enabled them to to weather the coveted
disaster for their revenues so there's a
lot of things that are favorable
it's who's went up
excuse if no if it's not acceptable to
nobody's Fighters objectives
went down it's not a free everybody
actually happens in the rest of the
world we pay twice the cost of every
other Every Other Nation on Earth so can
you lower the price of American medical
program that we have high deductibles
that we were the highest deductible this
is the bill that you were talking about
yes we in in 2021
um we were the second highest cost of
deductibles in New Hampshire in the
country who do you think decides what
the deductible should be who do you
think does this insurance company no the
employer the employer looks at the
premium and looks at the deductible and
then makes a debt decision how much
deductible they want to you know how
much they think they can suffer onto
their employees they can afford from the
insurance company right they the
insurance company runs what will set the
price to that employer to the deductible
and the premium they're directly related
okay in other words if I wanted if I
wanted to lower my deductible
as an employer if I want to lower my
deductibles to my employees I just have
to pay a higher monthly premium chairman
hunt you're absolutely correct in what
you're saying okay what we're saying is
that the total cost of Health Care to an
employer or to an employee is based is
is set by the insurance company the
insurance company says look we're going
to make thirty thousand dollars a year
off of you chairman of chairman hunt
either through the deduct through the
premium or the deductible we can lower
your premium and raise your deductible
and meet that thirty thousand dollars a
year or we can lower your raise your
premium and lower your deductible so
what you're saying is as an employee or
employer I can determine which of those
two programs I want but from the
insurance company they don't care
because they're making the thirty
thousand dollars a year off of you and
your employee regardless of which plan
you choose
but again that the individual the
individual business is the one who's
making that decision so if you were to
say to me why do we have so many so what
you're saying is is that in Maryland
they have they don't have a five
thousand dollar deductible so there's
another issue which isn't which is
related to this that I want to discuss
with you
in short medical insurers are actually
like a utility
they get the opportunity the ACA set
that they can take aside 20 of revenues
taken from premiums and deductibles and
co-pays all the various tools
coinsurance if you wish to call all the
various tools that are that a health
insurer creates to get revenue from
from that they they must expend 80
percent of that on actual medical care
so the healthcare dollar actually goes
to Medical Care the rest of that 20
percent
goes to overhead to new buildings goes
to profit
the reason that such a phenomena is all
pair systems lower cost to answer your
question from before and thank you for
for clarifying what how the insurance
companies set these prices is the
insurance companies don't really care
very much how much they pay to the
hospitals
fact that your premiums are going up is
because of the response that the
hospitals are charging more
this is what I'm getting at you and I
don't think no I get what you're saying
so so each year
but just just an important an important
evidently representative Terry really
wants to okay step in here but you
understand the point that this is not
about me
so Mr chairman I just observe that it
sounds to me like what we're doing is
discussing the nuts and bolts of a
single-payer system and its merits or
demerits which my understanding is that
this would be the responsibility of the
study committee
to do not for this committee to do today
and I am particularly fascinated Mr
chairman and colleagues but the fact
that the two states that have been cited
these laws have been implemented have
been passed and implemented in states
where the Democrats aren't were in
control in Maryland and the Republicans
were in control in of the house in the
senate in Pennsylvania so this
fascinates me and put pushes me in the
direction of really wanting to learn
more about this before I decide whether
I would be predisposed favorably or
unfavorably to such a system on the face
of it there are people who are writing
to me people who are particularly
inclined to be supportive of me who are
calling this socialized medicine
and uh a a a Canadian model with all of
the of the of the disasters stories
anecdotal stories and statistics we get
out of Canada
I think it's premature to call something
something that it may not be so I would
be
um I would I would appreciate if we
could move to decide whether or not we
want to even Empower a study committee
or we just want to kill this thing right
now
representative this is not a a
single-payer system there is a bill to
that effect all payer includes all
private insurers it does not eliminate
the private insurers it just lowers
costs by making it transparent and the
negotiating process it takes care of the
pricing failures that exist with the 80
20 rule from the ACA and the opaque
negotiations so thank you thank you Ms
highlights once again the fact that
there's a lot of Education that needs to
be done around this so that they're
going to be a greater understanding
before we come to a decision
I thank you thank you so Mr chairman my
question to you
if we were to pass this
and I made sure you're the first name
is this punishment then you would be
chair of this study do you want to do it
you can always become a Dem go ahead no
do you want do would you want to do this
study committee remember Governor Hogan
was the governor of Maryland during all
of this time
right but in Pennsylvania the
legislature only recently
than Republican so I don't know it's
been Republican for the last uh two or
three four terms right but how when did
it pass in Pennsylvania by Republicans
when did it pass when did it passing
it's been under invest it was being
studied for the past four years yeah no
it hasn't passed in Pennsylvania no it
did pass and it passed I think uh two
years ago well so it's actually right
now it's law in Pennsylvania years ago
the Republicans controlled the house in
the Senate they just flipped one house
in the last election okay
I'm looking for four people who want to
do this study this okay so that if you
guys are all willing to do it then let's
just pass this and good luck
no actually this is great for you guys
to learn learn what study committees how
they work and what happens you're gonna
You're Gonna Learn first aid but I want
you to cherish I I have cheering skills
Mr chairman but that does not
necessarily mean that I'm everything
like you're first named you're going to
be on it you're going to be the chair
okay all right okay all right so the
motion of Representative Terry that's
great second representing collabro
so we are
I I
uh okay so the committee recommends
Terry
collabro post
just great
and who's who's my fourth
no I got post
thank you for looking to advance uh
who's my four exception yeah I just want
you to know what I find insane about
this is I've been around too long so we
used to have a law called most favored
nation
and that is that whatever the uh One
Insurance Company agreed to in terms of
the contract then all the other ones got
to be at the same rate
okay and so we got rid of that because
we thought we wanted a competitive
market that insurance companies could be
negotiating with each individual
hospitals based upon their Hospital
situation what's the best situation for
them competing and which ones they could
drive more customers to and then they
that rate that they would negotiate
would be based upon how many customers
how many you know clients they're going
to be sending to that particular
hospital and again you know make it up
in volume so if you think if if there if
you're telling me that hiring a third a
state bureaucracy creating a statement
it's actually using your existing
bureaucracy I just looked up another
website there are 12 different Health
Systems the health bureaucracies what
are you talking about democracies
Department of Health yeah I want to
thank you for voting on this by the way
you and I both remember when there was
no such thing as a for-profit health
insurance uh other than a person there's
Blue Cross we have one in state we
remember when there were also such
things as high risk risk pools and such
things as pre-existing conditions we
remember numerous things
agreed and thank you for moving who is
my fourth
you're gonna do it okay
okay
the motion is uh to
ought to pass
all those in favor raise their hand
okay one two three
four five those opposed
who's the six who am I missing
five to two okay
okay
what a waste of time
all right establishing an interstate
compact for Universal Health Care
Okay so
this one runs on the idea if I
understand if I remember correctly that
if we just had
one Insurance product
in the New England states
then we could drop
the premium by 15 is that right
you know you get that right
if
nothing
so the idea here is it's fairly simple
if we buy Health Care in bulk
we'll get a lower price for it
that's where the interstate compact
comes in
we work with other states so that we
have a higher population base that we're
covering our neighbor States whoever
else in the United States wants to join
us and therefore we're able to negotiate
prices with the hospitals with the
pharmaceutical companies all that sort
of stuff
um and and just sort of centralize
everything in one spot
um so we get one price for everything
um I don't I don't know if it would be
15 more or less
um because it would depend on the exact
number of states in the compact
um the exact numbers
um but yes it would cut costs and save
money
Okay so
yes representative I guess my question
is
you you don't yet have people who have
agreed to be in this compact is that
right
um we have talked to folks in
Massachusetts
um in Maine who are these folks are they
decision makers
um there is currently a bill in
Massachusetts that would create a system
like this it's just not interstate
compact I believe there has been in the
past similar things in Maine and Vermont
as well and also out west as well but
you don't yet have decision makers who
have said we want to do this
so correct I don't live in other states
so I'm not clear how we can
still be establishing an interstate
compact unless we have the players you'd
be the first what happens is you pass
the bill and the bill sits there
um until other states join it it doesn't
go into effect until other states have
joined
there's no no risk involved okay for you
here
if no one else wants to do it nothing
happens right and and yes representative
so hypothetically let's say that Vermont
and Maine and Massachusetts
and New Hampshire were to form in such
an interstate compact uh what would be
the decision-making process
who who would be the players and what
Authority would they have what vote
would they have I'm concerned here that
by
um becoming a party to an interstate
compact but not necessarily agreeing
with the other players that one would
have to go along with the majority
whatever the majority decides and we
already know that there are significant
differences represented by these four
states for example
what how do you respond to that
I mean at the end of the day
um regardless of which side of the aisle
you're on you need health care
um the needs between you know you and
any other members of
this committee here are fairly similar
regardless of of what letter is next to
your name you all need to see a doctor
um what the interstate comeback does is
it would establish a board to determine
those sorts of things
um at the end of the day they're just
making sure that that you're able to see
the doctors you need to see to get the
care you need to get you are able to get
the drugs you need this is not
rocket science here it shouldn't be
controversial
um the intent here is to to get us back
to sort of the pragmatic let's just get
everyone what they need
representative spear
uh realizing that I'm not allowed to
vote
that's true but you can but I can say
something you can say something
so there's there's really excuse me
there's really two issues
with
uh the funding of this
one issue is
what representative Terry talks about in
the fact that if we don't get enough of
a a base we're not going to be able to
do anything anyway right and that's what
you've said the other funding issue is
the Assumption which we have talked
about that you are not going to get
people from Medicare and you're not
going to get self
-insured people like BAE Systems CNS
CNS grocery
Fidelity all the self-insurers wouldn't
even be allowed to touch this so what
does that leave us
that leaves us a fairly small bucket of
people in this state
influenced by people from out of the
state
this this thing either needs to be
reworked
or it's just not not tenable and I'm not
going to say anything else because I
don't want to drive anybody else crazy
may I respond to that um
it's not a given that the
waiver from the federal government or
Medicare funds to be pulled into
distrust fund it most certainly is I
have looked at this in detail it cannot
be done unless we get together with
two-thirds of the states of this country
which we had no chance of doing well we
have information that you don't need an
act of Congress you can
as well as administrative orders by the
president
can because uh raw Canada from
California has a bill which calls for
different from the ACA waiver process a
waiver pathway there I'm sorry there are
lots of bills floating around just like
this one
pleading with Medicare to do this
pleading with Medicaid to do that they
don't accept the bills show me a bill
that has actually passed and they've
gotten money out of Medicare now
remember Medicare isn't paid by taxes
it's paid out of a fund directly from
the treasury they people don't have
access to that money
representative spear as I explained to
you um over email I believe we don't
need a Medicare waiver
um what would happen is folks on
traditional Medicare like you yourself
as you told me
um would receive a supplemental plan
from the interstate compact because we
can't necessarily touch that money
without
um Congress changing something which may
or may not happen of course
um
we just give you a supplemental plan to
cover the stuff that Medicare doesn't
cover
um and that way we don't need the
federal government money because they
just keep paying for it as they would
normally
um and the interstate compact would
handle the rest then in that case where
are you going to get the funding the
other people that can't that you cannot
touch are the people that are
self-funded the insurance companies that
are self-funded they are governed at the
federal level so that's what does that
lead correct as is funded
as I explained to you
um under erisa um companies that operate
in multiple states are required to offer
um Insurance the same insurance plan to
all of their employees that doesn't mean
that those employees have to use that
insurance plan
um and if they don't use it the company
doesn't have to pay for it all right
I've been under personally I've been
under that kind of insurance plan all of
my life all of my working life not once
not ever and that's older than you
no one not ever so anybody been allowed
to opt out of those plans
the way that this would work is
um
companies aren't going to want to pay
for the same thing twice they have two
options they can and keep encouraging
people to pay it for their use the erisa
plans or they can encourage them to go
on the interstate compact plan which
would cost them less
and so because that's a better option
for them but they can't use it
if you are governed underneath if you
are a self-insured company selfish wood
like BAE Systems you must offer the
exact same plan to everybody in the
company from the president down to the
guy who cleans the garbage I wish they'd
got rid of so they don't have those guys
opt out that is not legal no one's no so
I I don't see how anybody in New
Hampshire can take advantage of it when
they're not allowed to touch it I'm
sorry
okay uh representative Burroughs the
second hit from representative uh hunt
moves uh inexpedient to legislate
yeah
any discussion on the motion of inexpion
to legislate
I just think that this bill is not ready
I just want it on record that I applaud
what you're doing you know I I think
there's you know benefit in looking at
this but I don't think this is ready to
roll
okay
um all those in favor of uh inexp mean
to legislate raise your hand
one two three four five six
who am I missing now
okay it's a clever okay
so
I did
okay
but
yeah because uh Vincent's not here today
okay
take zero
hmm
all right it's moving right along
uh related to billing for ambulance
services
do you want to just retain this yeah I
would like to retain um the ambulance
service bill
um the more I thought about it and and
um talk to people involved I'm actually
looking into
um idea of finding federal or uh grants
from from for Rural
um that we might get for Rural ambulance
services so I'd like to explore that as
a possible alternative to legislation so
therefore I'd like to retain it
okay so if if I understand Mr chairman
so you're exploring non-legislative
alternatives
so that legislation would not be
necessary but you want to retain the
legislation anyway
I'm not 100 sure I'm saying I'm not 100
sure at this point whether we can find
money but I would like to do so
and use the legislation as a fallback oh
so you essentially want to put this on a
hold or put it in the freezer in case
you want to bring a deep Breeze well how
would you like to do it you want to itl
no I'm just asking a question I just
want to understand this is not this will
no longer be your primary vehicle
because you're going to be exploring
other Alternatives that you think more
may be more favorable but I'm saying I
don't know at this point to your
objective uh representative if if she
were to find another source right
then we would need to revisit the
legislation the statute to correct the
stat the statute that would reflect that
Revenue because in this bill was the
Banning of balance billing so if she was
to find other sources so they would take
care of those ambulance services that
that are need to do the balanced billing
that if that they have now been
satisfied by another source then we
could go forward with passing the bill
with the ban on balance billing
understood that's why she wanted to
retain it considered Prudence by
representative Earls thank you okay
thank you
okay she's back Mr chairman yes
representative Gibbs
um there was also uh another element of
this bill
um which uh is something that I think um
we would want to discuss on retaining it
and that was the requirement that the
insurance companies pay the ambulance
services directly rather than paying the
patient and then
um having it be the patient who then has
to pass the money onto the ambulance
service which sometimes happens and
sometimes does not happen which
obviously caused a lot of problems for
the ambulance services that didn't get
paid so I think that's something that we
would also want to discuss
um that makes it worthwhile retaining
the bill there you go
okay
all right so the motion is to retain all
those any discussion on the motion
teen none all those in favor raise your
hand
one two three
four
five six seven
but okay so seven zero seven zip
all right relative provider contract
standards for pharmacy benefit managers
so we want to retain this is that right
we're going to retain this
um okay
so representative hunt
seconded by representative Burroughs
actually
I don't even see your name
uh
no
okay
all right representative Terry
uh moves to retain no you do when I
second you yes you're seconding you're
second in the retaining motion
okay
uh
okay all those in favor of retaining
raise your hand one two three
four
[Music]
five six seven okay
getting there how are we doing for time
okay relative to Consumer Protection to
to hospital price transparency
I really liked this bill for whatever
it's worth even though I'm not on the
committee you really like this bill oh
yeah I mean I like I like what they're
trying to get at I was impressed by the
gentleman from Colorado who explained it
how I was working there and it led to a
lot of outcomes I think it's a I think
it's a good idea and I don't think it
runs
um I I think you I think you had concern
at the time that it was a little
redundant to what the states like but
because we just learned that there's
this cms.gov Health Plan price
transparency resource so I'm assuming
what we just learned is what they were
trying to get at that that those numbers
are being posted
it might am I am I assuming correctly
exactly but I think it doesn't provide
like another spot where they like you
can go into their website and find out
this so it's like another place for this
information to be available versus
assuming everybody knows about this
right
um Mr chairman I I don't I don't have a
problem with that the problem I have
with the was the penalty
is that not paying yeah that that's the
problem I have
so yes representative Mr chairman as I
recall
uh
I I too was impressed with the testimony
of the representative from Colorado who
informed us that it passed the Colorado
house I believe 99 to 1. however the
presentation that was made by the the
sponsor Prime sponsor and the supporting
sponsor left me with a lot of questions
with respect to how this would work and
be implemented in New Hampshire which
still whereas this sounds like I would
have voted for it in Colorado I I'm not
nearly as ready to vote for it here in
New Hampshire because the responses and
the information that I received from the
sponsor and the co-sponsor left me with
a lot of questions I don't think it's
ready for New Hampshire
okay representative spear
if I remember correctly the bill 389
talked about having
almost daily updates to the website
that's a website to keep and the
accuracy had to be very close
based on what we heard from the
insurance company uh the insurance
department rather
they're working like crazy and they're
trying to get it updated once a quarter
so I don't know is it physically
possible to even do what this bill wants
to do
right well and then and then the issue
yeah the issue is what what database
they are looking at I mean I assume it's
supposed to be maintained by the
hospital is the hospital supposed to be
keeping this thing published
well I mean I think they were going to
be posting all that information on their
respective hospital websites so that
when somebody's looking to get a knee
surgery done they could go to each
website of right of the local hospitals
and they compare I think the part that
sound interesting to me was yeah I mean
well what the gentleman from Colorado
said with respect to your concern was
that I think he said that nobody had
ever gotten to a point where they had to
take someone to court and I was also
concerned with that too and I raised
that question that that they usually
gave him a reef they would give them
enough so it was a negotiating point
that you've got to give me a discount
because you screwed up and he said
nobody nobody had got to that point
because they figured it out in advance
how to negotiate it versus going to
court because it would going to court is
that's that's expensive on the person
bringing them to court too so I feel
like there was an incentive on both
parties to negotiate
um what I thought was super interesting
and
I know it's not directly the intent of
this build but maybe uh an unintended
positive consequence of the bill was the
idea that there were these apps and tech
companies that were popping up to have
this information tied to your location
you could quickly scan it and he said
that that had been popping up in in
Colorado and perhaps a similar ecosystem
could pop up here which would no offense
and with all respect to the insurance or
the what the presentation we had today
would probably be
um
you know Superior to what the government
is producing for us now well I can tell
you there won't be because the one thing
you can't do is tell you what the doctor
or the anesthesiologist or anybody else
who's also Billy
because you get separate bill those are
separate bills
that's true I mean I'm just saying that
was the big project we had for for the
Department was we want we want the net
we want the net we don't want the gross
we want with everybody all the different
providers who were who were in the room
yeah I mean I thought it was I thought I
still thought it was an interesting
thing to have like I go on my phone and
I'm like I'm in Concord and what are the
three hospitals nearby I need to go get
my leg x-rayed after I fell off my bike
or something and you could like
you know I mean that's that that's
emergency room yeah yeah and that in
that example sure but I mean I think
that that's kind of a an interesting
outcome that he says is starting to pop
up in Colorado and I I don't know it
seems I didn't see a huge downside to
this aside from what downside to me is
the threat that they won't pay the bill
at all
and the last thing I want to do is
create a situation where that right or
some technicality it's almost you know
which I agreed with and I I asked that
question of them and but I was I was
impressed by the gentleman's answer from
Colorado which is it hasn't happened
there because hey there's a cost to take
somebody to court right and B once you
get to that point if you know you're out
of compliance you have an incentive to
negotiate with them versus going to
court and getting you know so I don't
know I mean I thought that was a good
explanation from the gentleman Colorado
okay that's all I take I'm not like
sorry to this but I was impressed by
everything will the hospital Association
like to uh
no comments from the peanut gallery
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee I unfortunately was in
another hearing so I did not hear the
Department's presentation on health
costs so I when you were sightings
um chairman hunt the CMS website I'm
assuming that's the CMS website relative
to
um the no surprises Act help plan price
transparency resource 500 items it's all
it's all part of the no surprises act no
surprise the um but that is probably
um and not to
um not to um throw my um carrier friends
under the bus but that might be for the
carriers the hospitals have to post as I
my testimony indicated that no surprises
Act is was is phased in and so I think
that might be relative to the carriers
right okay that could be wrong the
hospitals we had to do this starting in
21 and they have been posting which act
was that that required you the same act
as just it was phased in because it's so
complex
um and that is where they have to they
have to um as my testimony indicated
that they are required to make available
on their websites single machine
readable digital file containing
standard charges up to 300 of their
common services so that's that was put
into effect a couple years ago and I
just think it's important to um to
comment everything in this bill is
already in in federal law
um so the the difference is so
the difference is has to do with the
collection piece which is what I think a
lot of people have concerns about what
the unintended consequences are that is
right and that is certainly something
that we um we're opposed to this entire
bill but that is another unintended
consequence another thing that I think
is important is websites are developed
now you don't need this law to in the
state of New Hampshire to to have
entrepreneurs
um develop
databases based on the no surprises act
based on the chis database we had that
now I'm trying to remember the
individual um I'm looking at my
colleagues back there um there might be
someone that was developing is it the I
forget the name but he has a company
um that it was actually remember he came
he was dressed as an owl oh I remember
that guy yeah yeah yeah that was good
that was cool um
yeah it was a while ago oh thank you uh
Mark Galvin um has a company yeah no
that was thanks thanks to Heidi she she
remembered his name mark Galvin has a
company that is doing just this and I
believe he is using some of the data now
available through the no surprises act
to develop his website even more and I
am forgetting what the company name is
um it's
owls yes it was
um anyway
um so I just wanted to make those points
you don't need this law to develop
websites and you and the piece that is
different in this bill has to do with
the collection piece which I believe has
a lot of unintended consequences and
furthermore we don't have an issue in
this state so why would we um we don't
support
um passing a law in New Hampshire right
when it's not needed
seems to me I remember
she said that last thing she said that
before and I asked which was one is the
the sponsors think there is a problem I
mean a half this half the hospitals are
not in full compliance with the law and
so they had a different but it had a
spreadsheet and so
um I I think my testimony
um disputed that um I did definitely did
yeah because the the federal government
HHS who oversees those um the the
compliance has indicated otherwise so
that unfortunately is there was
misinformation
um and because this this company that
they were referencing
um the
uh I don't have the letter in front of
me but um when we sent oh the patient
rights advocate.org and when we um sent
a letter to the Attorney General's
office
um that was also part of my testimony I
think that clarified okay great so Mr
chairman if it sounds like the
information
that was being that is being sought
by this bill is already being required
under federal statute is just not being
presented in the same way or the same
format or whatever as envisioned by the
sponsors of this bill
uh so we really don't have a lack of
information we do have the information
it's there and to the entrepreneur issue
apparently
um we don't NEC we don't need a law in
order to make the market work it sounds
like even though Colorado may be a
little further along with respect to
startups in the technology that it's
it's it's already starting to happen
here in New Hampshire so the the major
concerns that are being addressed by
this bill
or thought to be addressed by this bill
have already been addressed
so we don't need to pass something if
the objectives sought in this bill are
already being fulfilled
thank you
I'm not a voting member so you're you're
going to get to vote on it well next
week so right we votes the committee
yeah I mean
I guess I
I would like to know if if they are in
compliance I know she's saying there are
I would like and then
when I spoke to the
um representative Phillips I think was
her name I mean she said that they
weren't and so they seemed to be
discrepancy and I'd like to know how we
know that for sure and
um
I mean I remember the testimony but uh
yeah I mean I guess what is the
mechanism right now if they're not in
compliance with the federal law who's in
charge of enforcing that is that Federal
Federal HHS the hospitals are have to
follow Federal that's what happens when
they don't so they there are major
penalties um but I am happy to I mean if
so if you want I mean every single yes
so the question here is I'm hearing he
said she said which do I know is true
can you provide for representative
Sullivan and the rest of us who may be
interested the documentation to
definitively defend your position such
that the claim being made by the
sponsors is shown to be deficient
yes I was going to say if he settles he
should she say right we can go on every
Hospital's website and give you the URL
that shows that they are in fact doing
what the no surprises act Law requires
them to do would that help
yeah well that settles the dispute am I
looking the right thing is this
spreadsheet here there was the Sim third
semi-annual Hospital price transpirinary
report from New Hampshire compliance
is that the chart that I handed out I
don't know what that is I don't think
you hit it out because half the hot more
than half the hospitals are
non-compliant no that's the one
oh okay yeah I did not get his testimony
and then their explanation of why my
hospital is standard charges file fails
to provide an adequate amount of
negotiated minimum negotiated negotiate
minimum negotiated maximum or negotiated
rates
yes so you're asking the hospitals to
supply metrics one set of metrics for
the federal government and one set of
metrics for the state government and we
get a report that that there are certain
hospitals that are not apparently
supplying all of the the data for the
metrics that are required whereas what
you're saying is that with respect to
the federal metrics the data is being
completely
supplied right and and therefore the the
legislation is being satisfied with
respect to compliance here in New
Hampshire right so there was a chart
that I handed out with my testimony
um not mine was color-coded that is from
from my testimony was that my that my
testimony yeah and there's a chart now
there was a letter and a chart
um
okay so do you have a copy of this do
you know no I don't
know so this is from
patient rights
advocate.org yeah unfortunately that's
attached to my testimony but that is not
my the chart I will send you I don't
know what happened there is a colored
chart
can I just do you mind if I just look at
that real quick so the one thing I could
say is this was all
these were uh last May and June
so and so it'd be nice to see what's the
latest their latest the screening is so
this this with the yes and no's that is
our analysis of the patient advocate
again what they were using in their um
report in their audit versus what CMS
requires which the hospitals have to
follow
um because they are all
have to be compliant with the federal
government because they are CMS um CMS
over you know so they'll lose some of
their CS they they can't be Medicare or
Medicaid um they would lose providers so
what we did is compare and then we can
show where the requirements match and
most of them do not so that's what this
is
but I think there was another chart that
the other group might have handed out
that I have not seen so how about we
just retain this and keep on I would
have to say on the face of it my problem
is I am very reluctant to be in the
enforcer of federal laws
and and passing state laws to enforce
federal laws that's fair
um and so that's that's where my
reluctance to get into this bill but uh
and then you're also imposing a second
set of requirements according to
patients rights advocacy that they have
these different metrics so now we're
saying to the hospitals well now you got
to supply these the responses on the
basis of these metrics to CMS right and
then you got to support now we get this
other set of metrics and now you got to
employ people to develop the responses
to these which is a new mandate that
would be a state mandate so you got
double you got double mandate and and
what's generating our mandate is some
third-party organization that you know
so my question is what's unsatisfactory
about the federal government I think
that's actually not what the law is
trying to do because it says that
they're trying to convene make sure
they're in compliant with federal laws
that's what I thought yeah that's how I
read the law I read the bills they
weren't the hospital administration's
arguing that they are but I think that
they're not trying to create a second
mandate but they were they were they
they they insisted that the website be
up to date like almost momentarily when
she was talking when the representative
was talking they expected it to be
updated Dynamic very quickly and also
much more accurately than we could ever
hope to do
so it is a set of other regulations on
top of the federal regulations in effect
it's a new mandate may not be doable is
it is that in here I don't see that
anywhere in here no she just saying that
that's what that was the test I think
she was saying that right because you
know frankly if if we were to pass this
I that I would want us to specifically
state which web page is the one
to be used I wouldn't say if you can
come in with any any old third party and
say you know they've got evidence
differently
um you know you would actually if you're
going to try to enforce it or you at
least hold up in court if not that they
would go there but to have legitimacy
it's got to be from a uh recognize we
got a in our statue we've got to
recognize the actual entity in which is
being the uh the I agree with that and
what hospitals even want to start
entering data in yet a second database
didn't we just hear it loud and clear is
that this is this you're never going to
get a good note you're never going to
get and you're never going to get them
to agree this is feel good law
legislation frankly
and oh that that's right Senator Hassan
was the sponsor wasn't she
and why why do we need to require the
state to do something where there is a
an asserted failure uh at the of the
federal at the federal level when it's
not been demonstrated that there is in
fact non-compliance with the Federal
Regulations I mean do we really have
something here that's going to improve
uh on the on the Federal Regulations I
did not hear that from the from the
sponsors
okay
so um help me understand the compliance
so
who says how are the New Hampshire
hospitals notified that they're either
in or out of compliance and then what
are the existing penalties
so the no surprises Act is very
extensive and there are requirements
that a that the federal government is
the one that um the the entity that will
be auditing the hospitals and have done
this periodically
um with all our many of the hospitals
throughout the country I think the
biggest issue is
what was being touted as saying the
hospitals are not in compliance was
using this other entity that did this
study did not follow the federal
government the hospitals have to follow
the federal law so this other entity
um this this independent Patient
Advocate did a different study and
that's what the sponsor was using to say
that the hospitals are not in compliance
my contention is they are in compliance
because we have already checked and the
state the federal government has not
cited them for not being in compliance
so the other problem is if you're not in
material compliance then that's the new
part of the and I agree with um
representative spirit that um there are
two standards because then if they're
not in compliance according to who then
the patient will be responsible will not
be responsible so you're then creating
this other other issue of collections or
not being able to collect so it just
added another layer that's the piece
that's the difference then it's still
the federal no surprises act but again
our contention is it is not necessary
because they are in compliance with
they're not I mean I'm the hospitals are
not are not going to be required to
follow the patient advocate and the
criteria sounds like they're different
like my as my chart shows the criteria
are different so of course the results
are going to be different so
representative Waltz
just a question why would you retain
versus itl yeah uh
Mr chairman absent rebuttal okay this Mr
chairman absent rebuttal from the
sponsor or one of the co-sponsors and
neither one of them are here today I
don't know how we retain something that
has been demonstrably shown as being
unnecessary okay
okay
[Laughter]
uh so someone else a member of this uh
okay representative Calabro
seconded by
representative post
moves itl any discussion on the motion
see none the clerk will call oh no all
those in favor say aye one two three
four five six and
seven zero
okay
okay one to go last to go relative
health insurance coverage for
preventable pfas care
this is a health insurance mandate
well the
the if I understand this building is he
is the sponsor here
oh there she is my understanding of the
bill is that if someone
someone wants a procedure
and says the reason she he or she wants
it is because they have high P fast
numbers
then
then they have to do the procedure that
we're mandating the procedure has to go
forward not quite
um okay so it it all what what triggers
the the uh not the procedures but the
follow-up and the monitoring and the the
um oversight of these people is if you
have a blood test and it's above that 20
point limit so that's what triggers all
of this care
that that 300 pages of care so it could
start you know with an infant you know
so you don't you don't wait for symptoms
you you get the blood test and that's
that's what triggers it
so but but what is the procedure that
you're then requiring
it it's all outlined in those those 300
pages so for an infant
um you would have screenings for
Disabilities you'd have screenings for
autism you would um starting I think
they they say at age one that you start
testing for cholesterol
um and and high blood sugar
so and these are things that that you
know a one-year-old is not going to be
able to tell you I've got no I'm not
worried about that part what I'm praying
about is when we talk about mandates in
this committee
um and and and I guess just give a
historic perspective many years ago
Dartmouth Hitchcock wanted to try for
breast cancer uh for solid breast
cancers they wanted to try to do
chemotherapy to this and
um and and they're basically put this
committee as plain doctor right we had
to determine whether this was
appropriate care we're bypassing the
medical directors of the insurance
companies and we were going to
unilaterally make this decision right we
passed it it turns out that they only
did it for a year and then realized it
didn't work Okay so
now I'm I'm uh as carrier of that
history okay is I'm I'm emphasizing is
is that what we have what we want to
deal with is
um we have situations where if that
um
let's take the rest was we found out
that some insurance companies were
waiting for a year and a day
in other words in terms of they were
saying they were doing breast uh tests
every two years rather than doing
annually yeah so then
we we were now
uh the legislation was for us to mandate
that yes it can be done manually all
right so
um what we're trying to what we're
dealing with in any legislation when it
comes to these Health procedures is that
we're dealing with an insurance company
won't do a procedure which that um that
your physician or the the generally
accepted Medical Practice
okay has said that that is appropriate
that that is these are appropriate so
that you have to in terms of way I read
this bill it seemed very open-ended it
wasn't specific it's very specific to
the guidelines and those are CDC
guidelines so that 300 Page there was
some confusion
um up here about where that that
document came from the CDC can uh can
got our con what I can't think of the
word contracted with with that agency to
develop these guidelines which are going
to be adopted by the CDC they were
supposed to be adopted in December but
there's been a change of directors So
eventually these guidelines are going to
be adopted they're they're in use in a
pediatric center right now and they're
referenced by pfas Silent Springs uh
I'm sorry Silent Springs organization on
the cape which is they do a lot of pfas
research
okay so and then and so if you're tested
and you have these things what are we
mandating which proceed what procedure
what are we mandating at that point all
of them all of them what is all that all
is not a good word uh what is the
specific okay representative Calabro
thinks he's an expert on this issue so
let's hear it not an expert I just read
the 300 Pages
um brilliant thank you an expert
um well I felt it was imperative seeing
that I am a PCP so um this is pertinent
to me thank you um I was very ill about
halfway through it reading these
protocols being aware of what is coming
down the pipeline
[Music]
um
I was concerned
um as a PCP who's being inundated
fighting insurance companies every day
something like this is going to impact
me pretty badly
um trying to order anything Medicare
Medicaid that is not completely covered
already is a huge battle we're already
under staff or you know profits are bad
so make this make sense for me
how are we going to
this is a start this is a start so I'm
in touch with our federal delegation to
try to get this passed also on a
national level right
and further inquiry further question
they inquired
once it is adopted federally and we know
there's delays and when that's going to
happen that I agree with you this is how
I'm going to practice medicine going
forward to cover my butt thank you okay
yeah but but the reality is insurance
companies may not be quite so forthright
to support those protocols which is why
we need to mandate them
because these these these Protocols are
not silly protocols as you if you've
read the document I mean they're they're
very specific it's real start with with
birth essentially actually it starts
with pre-birth because the mother has to
be tested
um and goes so it's it's Cradle to to
casket you know birth to death all of
these and and so it's
as you get older you know you don't get
the same tests every single year you get
modified tests based on the criteria
that was established and if you look at
the first page of that document I mean
there's many many organizations that
have contributed to this this is not oh
it's cumulative meta-analysis I think
from everything throughout the country
basically to try and bring forth
something that the CDC will say yes this
is fine right and I get that and so and
if if you recall the reason that this
came about is that I had an operation
that was initially denied and I had um I
heard of a young woman in our town who
has breast issues and she was told she
was too young you know so so that's the
reason is that we have a p pass problem
in in New Hampshire we have it you know
it's here we're we're suffering and so
this is a way to protect and to
Institute so just because the CDC is
going to adopt these guidelines doesn't
necessarily mean that all of the states
are going to adopt them you know or that
insurance companies are going to adopt
them
you know I we're going to uncover a lot
of problems earlier which is good for
people but it's not good for insurance
companies
right and you realize this only affects
a third of the state's population I do
which is why I am in touch with the uh
the federal delegation to see if we can
maybe do something for Medicaid or
Medicare right
um Mr chairman
yes representative Rose
um just just before I asked my question
you said it only impacts one-third do
you mean because it's in the southern
part of the state no because under our
statutes there that other entities are
exempt so if you're Medicare Medicaid or
an employer large employer which is
known erisa yeah we our legislation
can't affect them okay all right so this
only is for small employers all right
small employers and the individual
Market because I assume I can't seem to
find that I would say a third
and if I mean if somebody you
discussion about
hi
um breast cancer you know if you if they
if a doctor or you find a mass you don't
say well you can't have a mammogram
because it's recommended in year two
you're gonna go see what's about you're
going to do a mammogram and see what
treatment is and again if blood tests
are showing that there's uh there's a
problem here we got to pay for it to see
what's going on right you know
particularly given what we're seeing in
terms of illness for people that you
know just to use that breast cancer
example
um you may not know that you have breast
cancer for years and years until you
feel a mass or something like that so
these young women and I'm talking early
20s that are that are starting to be
positive with cancer they there they
might not even know that they have I
mean we need preventive care
excuse me for these these young women
who have been horribly exposed to pfas I
mean it the damage is done it's in their
body now we need to take care of them I
I totally agree with you yeah thank you
what is the definition what what is the
definition of preventative pfas care
well it's essentially following the
guidelines that are uh that are
identified in that 300 page
um right and it you have to and the the
insurance fellow that was here Alex I
don't remember
yeah and he was he was quoting from a
chart and he was saying he couldn't
understand what the problem was because
the guidelines are already established
that's a chart from that document that
300 Page document right so therefore it
is covered Mr Sherman it is why is it
not covered because it hasn't been fully
adopted yet cdc's may I ask for
clarification yes representative Gibbs
thank you
um yes the CDC guidelines referenced in
the bill
the that is that 300 Page document which
was developed
um by an organization under a contract
with the CDC but has not yet been
adopted by the CDC but the CDC plans to
adopt it is that correct it was supposed
to be adopted within six months after
publication however um and that would
have been December of last year but
there there's been a directorship change
at the CDC and so they've they've put it
on do we know when it is going to be
adopted we don't know right now but
there is no so the hold up is has
nothing to do with the content of the
publication I wasn't asking about that I
was just asking about them it has to do
with with
politics within not politics that's the
wrong word but
employee shuffling that's probably
better
but it is it your understanding and that
of other stakeholders that this is going
to be adopted in short order and that is
that those are the guidelines correct
that are specified in the bill correct
thank you correct so what I'm trying to
get at is that what is the preventative
what is what is actually what is what
what procedure or what process what
medication what is being given that has
not been given by insurance companies
now
that's a very broad-based answer but if
you were to talk if you walked into my
office I'm going to do a blood level I'm
going to go and I'm going to start from
there right okay you got you got a big
highlight memories of your foot yeah
I've got to get your history I've got to
get all of your history and I need to
assess your risks according to these
protocols great okay so when I see
certain things say I get a red flag I
get a feeling in my gut something's not
quite right I may need to order Imaging
I may need to order things to do further
evaluation to look for those risks
okay in a woman this is a little bit
easier because of the of the um
the way it plays in with hormones and
how much more prevalent it is I feel
going to be for women this is a little
bit more of an easy discussion as far as
that's concerned but there are protocols
these are the things that I have to
follow okay these things will be adopted
by the CDC the AMA will approve all of
those things so nothing that's in that
document that 300 Page document is under
scrutiny or question
okay it's just a timing thing here
but again if we're going to be mandating
something yes what are we actually
Manning are we mandating that you should
be able to order a a a scan yes
yes so right now when you order when you
say is a scan you have to put a
diagnosis in right I would have to um
and now you have an elevated piece I
would have to find out what codes would
be eligible first right before I play
that game and then um and then and that
way I don't end up having to well that's
what I'm saying if you can already do
that now then that won't be legislated
because it's not covered yet it's not
covered so you're saying that right now
there is no code
we're going to be mandating the creation
of a code the codes exist okay so there
is a code yes sir so the code is the
this person has elevated pfas so and and
you are concerned that this person might
have a tumor growing in them so
therefore you can't if you ordered up
this
the insurance company would fuse it
that's correct
that's correct so if I have a patient
you know what I want to do what I want
to do is is I think I've just got that
question out yeah
we have insurance department and we have
insurance companies we have I see
three four here okay you know they're
all represented here so that's your
charge to tell us is the you are are you
declining now these things so we need
this information otherwise you know
otherwise I think we would just
otherwise let's retain the bill
to I mean I I we can do we can do
another hearing do this again next week
you can bring them up you're gonna ask
them one two three four yeah and and
they'll come up and they'll probably see
whether they're gonna cover these things
all right so we'll adjourn this
subcommittee unless representative you
have something new
um we were dealing with pfas there are
so many different
um variations of it that they were
taking little chunks of it at a time to
you know put them on the books so I mean
I know we say pfas but that is a huge
umbrella so I can't imagine there's a
code for every single one of those right
now
just know and that 20 um that 20 uh
points I think it's nanograms in the in
the blood that's total so that that
covers all of the ones not just
okay right I didn't realize that so the
other thing is is that this if if I mean
we've been talking about women if if a
man walks in and he's you know of adult
age
and is showing High pfas you would
typically not start screening him for
prostate cancer until he's much older
but with this he starts getting screened
earlier
if you if you're if you're an adult even
if you're a child and you have high
pfest they have to start scanning your
not scanning I don't mean you know
Imaging but they have to start looking
out for kidney cancer because that's
gonna that's gonna pop up well it could
pop up eventually
yep
okay yeah so so this is to put in place
screening based on that blood work and
and it's to avoid patients like me
having to spend hours on the phone
trying to justify a surgery with an
insurance company because you know it
wasn't in the books or it wasn't
recognized
insurance
it was it was one of the people around
me and I hope it wasn't an arrestor no
no well it was through my husband's uh I
he works for red hat so that's a fairly
large business
yeah I I'd have to look that up
yeah but I'm working on it in Washington
sure
I would be very interested yeah what
I would challenge if they say it's all
covered but you can you can hear what
they say yep
okay
everybody well there are lots of things
are not available
committee
it said that the last thing we would see
over there is a dash k
Ash Amy there's an actual appropriation
that means you guarantee that the early
Bill and it has to refinance
I'm looking at the fiscal note on this
one and it's all zero and indeterminable
so we'll take it up next uh well I
actually now that I think about it
because it's not an early bill I might
push this off till later for us to work
on it
okay
yeah I don't this we're in this
subcommittee is over
um
oh yeah we gotta push it out yeah one
Thirty
well right now we're supposed to be 1 15
right
yeah 1 30. okay
with me
okay
[Music]
I'm going downstairs Sean okay it's a
little too much to go to Tangers yeah
foreign
on
we're doing
thank you
sorry for the delay everyone
call the hearing to House Bill 242 to
order
and we'll hear from the prime sponsor uh
representative Dunn and
okay
the prime sponsor is not here
Murphy
Wendy Thomas
anybody here representative Thomas would
you like to introduce this bill since
you're a co-sponsor all right we'll keep
get things moving
pull that mic close to your mouth and
make sure the red light is on thank you
good afternoon members of the committee
it's good to be back
um actually I didn't leave but um I am
representative oh
you we're introducing sorry I apologize
all right if you want to double team it
or however you like I do have something
to say yeah eventually okay
first I apologize I'm across the hall in
executive session so I'm trying to
Double Do Double Duty so I apologize
good afternoon committee chair
my name is representative Dunn
Londonderry I'm here today to speak to
this Bill thank you for allowing me to
speak to it pfas is a group of chemicals
that are tasteless have no smell are
invisible making them virtually unknown
to the average person pfest chemicals
are listed as a forever chemical meaning
they never go away
pfas is a chemical that according to the
agency for toxic substances and disease
registry they can cause immune problems
kidney cancer testicular cancer high
cholesterol thyroid disease
and this is only a small sample of the
problems caused by pfas pfas is a
chemical that you don't want to ingest
in any quantity
no amount of pfast is acceptable
pfas affects not only humans but pets
Wildlife fish to name a few
fast food retailers such as Chick-fil-A
Wendy's Chipotle have removed pfast
already from their packaging
McDonald's Burger King Popeyes have all
committed to remove the pfas from their
food packaging by 2025.
grocery chains such as Trader Joe's
Whole Foods are currently using pfast
free food packaging
there should be no tax money spent on
this bill
and states that have already passed the
ban on pfast and food packaging they put
the onus on the manufacturer in order to
sell food packaging in these states the
manufacturer must comply must provide a
certificate of compliance in order to
sell their product in that state
the incent of this bill is to prevent
further exposure to pfas from food
packaging
by reducing pfas and food packaging we
hope to reduce the health costs
associated with what this forever
chemical causes to People's Health
this bill will also remove pfas from
food packaging in the waste cycle
this will thus reduce the amount of
pfast going to landfills thus reducing
the amount of pfast that can leach into
the groundwater
and when it is burned released into the
air
this bill will also not raise any costs
on small business
a study was done by the department of
ecology and the state of Washington
they have identified that there are less
hazardous Alternatives that are already
available in the market
that will cause no Financial impact to
any small business or to the average
consumer
in conclusion Mr chair and committee
members pfas is a forever chemical that
never goes away
we need to limit our exposure to this
forever chemical and remove it from all
food packaging no amount of this
chemical is safe
the intent of this bill is to put the
onus on the manufacturer and not the
taxpayer
this bill is one way we can help keep
our citizens and children safe from this
forever chemical called pfas
thank you Mr chair and committee for
your time today I'm happy to take any
questions if there's anything related to
health and science there's much smarter
people than me sitting behind me that
can answer those questions thank you for
your time I'll see you next exactly
sitting next to me yes thank you and uh
in the interest of time representative
Thomas would you like to testify and
then if if you don't mind both taking
questions together then sure sure
absolutely I'm representative Thomas I
represent the town of Merrimack pfas
chemical oh and thank you for letting me
uh testify in front of you
um pfas chemicals are often called
Forever chemicals because they do not
break down in the environment pfas are
are used in food packaging to prevent
grease and water from soaking through
food wrappers and beverage cups pfas can
also be found in the ink used to print
logos and instructions on food
containers
this raises alarms about the use of
these compounds especially in items such
as Burger wrappers and salad bowls these
these substances directly migrate into
the food you eat especially when that
food is hot it's especially likely when
food is fatty salty or acidic like pizza
some research even suggests that pfas
levels are higher in people who
regularly eat out
identifying the exact type of pfas in a
product is complex there are more than
nine thousand known pfas chemicals yet
common testing methods can identify only
a couple dozen
Consumer Report tested products for
their total organic fluorine content
which is considered the simplest way to
assess a materials total pfest content
that's because all pfas contain organic
fluorine
and there are a few other sources of
that compound
California had banned intentionally
adding pfas starting in January 2023
paper food packaging must have less than
100 parts per million organic fluorine
Denmark has settled on a 20 parts per
million as their threshold and the
consumer reports experts support the 20
PPM limit
Denmark Maine New York Washington and
Vermont have already banned pfest from
food packaging while Minnesota New York
and Connecticut have purchasing policies
bearing packaging with the chemicals
California Minnesota and Maryland are
concerned are considering phase-out laws
and or developing regulations
if you go to the CDC website for pfas
advice one of the first things they
state is to quote stop the source that's
easy when you have known products like
Glide dental floss or shoe water
repellent but it's not easy to do if the
chemicals are hidden by businesses in
their containers
one objection to this is cost to
businesses they would need to switch to
non-p fast food storage containers but
many companies are already doing that
McDonald's Wendy's and Whole Food Market
are among the at least 15 companies that
have announced policies in recent years
to phase pfas out of packaging that they
use or sell
let's also talk about the reaction of
the consumer recently simply tropical
juice was recalled because it contained
too much pfas
in a class action suit the plaintiff's
third-party testing showed that the
presence of multiple pfas in the simply
tropical juice included more than 100
times the EPA recommended recommended
levels of pfoa and pfos I can tell you
now that as a consumer a mother and a
clean water Advocate simply tropical
juice has lost my trust I expect a
product to be safe when I purchase it
and when it is not when it contains
chemicals that can make me sick then
that product has lost my respect and my
business forever
thank you
all right questions from the committee I
think I saw representative Spears hand
first I was going to ask the question
and you may have answered it uh I will
what kind of packaging is high in pfas
so anything that repels Greece so the
the biggest ones are Burger wrappers and
pizza boxes and uh Chipotle Chipotle
restaurant had um pfas coated Bowls
because they have hot rice that they put
into those things
the the balls so
and representative filo Valley
oh so close
how do you intend for this bill to be
enforced I see that uh on the second
page we have municipalities she'll be
the sole Authority
uh but what would happen if a
municipality decided to set the fine at
zero
if I could um ask DS to speak to New
Hampshire because they have a plan for
that oh okay is it possible so um
apparently Des will be up and they'll
they'll cover that
so we'll hold the question for the next
uh test of testimony uh representative
purcelli
Porcelli
thank you um
how are the uh let's see the
containers or the um
service products are they labeled how
would uh food service business no not
use a particular supplier because
they're high in pfast food packaging
um is there would require certificate of
compliance I'm sorry we would require a
certificate of compliance
certificate of compliance couldn't hear
that
for the packaging right so is there
something on the package that says no
pfas chemicals were used in this package
I mean how would I know when I'm buying
bowls not to buy them I I think it's
simple uh similar to the BPA
um you know a couple years ago we we
banned BPA and we couldn't it was in
baby bottles and all that kind of stuff
and so now
um
Industries and businesses don't use BPA
and they actually say you know no BPA in
this product so it would be similar to
that whole process
has that already been implemented so I
know not to buy these particular
products the pfas ones yes no it has not
that's the problem is we don't know
we're getting food containers from these
businesses that are coded in pfas and we
are not aware of it that's that's the
whole reason for this bill
so is there going to be some type of
notification how you know notification
well it would be com compliance
um but uh it's his bill
it would be compliance and to answer the
past question I just pulled it up what
we were trying to do is with this bill I
I had put an amendment forward leave
this committee likes to do their
amendments on in in subcommittee so
what the amendment would hopefully put
forward is that the Northeast Waste
Management officials Association would
be the group of people that would
um get the certificate of compliance
okay uh I'm sorry uh we'll go
representative uh Burroughs and then
representative Walsh
um just before I ask my question I think
we would like to see your Amendment the
committee would like to see it
um the amendment's out there I I don't
believe that the chair he when I spoke
to the chair he said that you guys do
all your amendments in-house
the amendment is already there it's it's
in the end you can email it to the
committee email address okay all right
and that would be good Absolutely I'll
do that okay but my all right here's my
question is that um
the um since that you need certification
the concern that was placed in the
fiscal note that municipalities would
have to test right is not a concern so
the amendment takes care of the fiscal
moment hopefully okay thank you
represent the wash
in order for this to be truly effective
don't you need it to be done at a
federal level because otherwise why
would companies say any of the you know
list what's in you know uh the
ingredients or pfas yeah
um absolutely and um again I'm working
with our federal delegation to try to
get that passed as well
I mean these These are bills that we're
proposing for New Hampshire because we
have a significant pfas problem in New
Hampshire they should be proposed for
the nation Because by the time you find
pfas in your water it's too late and
pfas has now become a national a
national issue so yes it should be a net
but until it becomes a national law
we've got to protect our residents in
New Hampshire now
all right any further questions
seeing seeing none thank you both for
your testimony thank you
just pass it up on the end there yeah
that's no
thank you
all right next we're going to call uh
Jody grimbless from American chemistry
Council
and she asks for two minutes
thank you
for the record my name is Jody gremlis
and I'm here representing the American
chemistry Council we have concerns about
the bill as presented I understand it
may be an amendment so we'd obviously
like
sorry
um so we'd like to get an opportunity to
take a look at that Amendment
um the American chemistry council is the
national trade Association of chemical
and plastic manufacturers including some
of our member companies here in New
Hampshire over 96 percent of
manufactured goods are are impacted by
the business of chemistry so it's kind
of an essential part of our nation's
economy the chemical industry supports a
comprehensive approach to managing pfas
and that would help to ensure protection
of human health and environment that
includes appropriate science-based
policies and regulations
so one of the things I would note about
the bill is that what I understand is
that there's significant levels of study
science and regulation being done at the
FDA so I did bring
information
for the committee about from the fda's
website about questions and answers on
pfas and food and also I off also
authorize uses of pfas in food contact
applications food packaging so again
it's being looked at at the national
level I think there was a question about
should this be a national policy we
would agree it would because Patchwork
regulations from different states is
often hard for the whole Supply food
chain but um I would leave this
information I'll pass it out as I'm as I
finish that you can look at and I will
tell you that I did double check the
authorized uses of pfas and food contact
there are pfas I think as representative
post mentioned and one of the other
committee hearings pfas is a wide
variety of chemicals with different
chemical infrastructures different
substances they're not all the same so
there are some that have been studied by
the FDA that are okay and safe for food
contact and there are some that are not
obviously some of the pfos and pfoas are
not so this document explains some of
that and so I will leave it with the
committee be available for subcommittee
and I hopefully be able to bring
somebody from the chemistry Council to
be actually able to answer the more
scientific questions
um but I'll leave it at that okay thank
you questions representative bellew yes
thank you
chair thank you for taking my question
present The Chemical Company
chemical industry chemical yes the
American chemistry so is that a conflict
of interest
testifying on this pfas no because they
manufacture it no that's the job of a
lobbyist yeah that's what a lobbies does
is represents
their client interests right no I'm 10 I
tend to not
believe her testimony because where it's
coming from we won't insult the
witnesses thank you for not appropriate
sorry representative Bros yes this is a
would you believe sure and um so would
you believe hypothetically we had a
botulism in some food supply that comes
into New Hampshire I don't think we
would wait to see what the federal
government was doing to address it and I
think that this is a really serious
health problem and I don't think that we
should be waiting to see what the
federal government does before we
address it here because we have people
getting sick and dying in the state I
understand I just want to bring forward
what they're doing thank you so much
thank you representative Spear and then
we'll go representative
thank you in line with representative
Burroughs was saying we have communities
here and my sister lives in one of them
and we're soon to be living in one they
are literally not allowed to drink the
water and they get water delivered to
their house from the company that's been
polluting all these years
and I agree we cannot wait for the
federal government and it seems like the
chemical industry is being just a little
bit Cavalier about the whole thing
what are you doing specifically are they
doing anything are they just sitting
there waiting no I don't think so I
can't speak for all all of the and again
I think I will bring somebody for the
subcommittee from the chemistry Council
so they can speak to all of the things
that they're doing I know 3M is not a
member of the association but I know
they have I think recently announced
that they're getting rid of all the pfas
that they have used in the past
um so I think there there's a true
recognition that pfas and pfoa and pfas
are problems
I believe so but I would prefer to have
somebody from the council speak to you
directly
but I will definitely put that in my
notes to get back to them to do
representative McLeary uh thank you uh
you mentioned right from the beginning
that you had objections as to the way
that this is written and again then you
refer to maybe it should be a federal
law but what specific uh problems with
the chemical industry have with uh
with this bill so there were a couple of
questions that they raised so for
example
um there's some language that's pretty
Broad and they were trying to understand
typically when they face these kinds of
when there are these policies passed in
various States they're very very
specific so for example
um a service product on line 16 talks
about means a food container Bowl plate
tray carton hot and cold beverage lid or
other item they're like what does other
item mean and so I think it's just the
specificity that would be if the
committee decides to move forward with
legislation to look at some of that
language and be very clear about what
you mean it's helpful for all of the
levels of the supply chain to the
consumer
representative Terry so with respect to
your knowledge of the laws that have
been passed by other states would you
say in general there is a
greater level of specificity such that
you do yeah the same kinds of concerns
that you do with this bill that
apparently has not been modeled as I've
asked for them to send me I think
representative Thomas mentioned Vermont
has passed Something New York has passed
something so I'm trying to see if I can
get those laws to see how different they
are okay thank you sure
representative Walsh
thank you
uh would you believe I do have a
question but I was a Plastics buyer for
Hewlett Packard at one time is your data
that you're going to pass out am I
correct in hearing what you said that
there are some forms of
pfas that do not Leach
in into uh you know humans as far as
they're used for various packaging
materials and they do not Leach because
having been a Plastics buyer there's
lots that's like saying all Plastics is
bad it's not I think that there's you're
going to provide us with some data that
shows correct there are different levels
correct acknowledging we do have a
problem in New Hampshire but there there
are some okay let's keep into questions
for the hearing correct I'll just say on
this which I will pass out the fourth
bullet is paper slash paper board food
packaging pfas may be used as grief
proofing agents and fast food wrappers
microwave popcorn bags take out paper
board containers and Pet Food bags to
prevent oil and grease from foods from
leaking but then it goes on further on
to tell you which which pfas
letters numbers Etc
um is actually the ones that have been
proven to be safe
all right thank you no further questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much
next we'll call Noah graze from the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and yes
for two minutes and he has a comment
thank you Mr chair I know my handwriting
is terrible it's nature Grace from the
municipal Association I don't believe
I've been in front of your committee
this year so briefly we are a volunteer
membership organization comprised of all
234 cities and towns we provide them
legal advice Education and Training and
of course we come here and Advocate the
sole issue that we had with this bill as
written is page two lines two and three
which gives municipalities the sole
authority to regulate Implement and
enforce the prohibition on Food Service
products containing pfas it's not that
we're not
concerned about the impacts of pfas on
on our citizens it just seemed
inefficient to have
municipalities uh be the ones to
regulate that when it's obviously we
live in a small state it seemed more
appropriate to have a Statewide
regulatory Authority in talking with the
prime sponsor he has uh drafted an
amendment that I believe addresses all
of our concerns so I would urge the
committee to look at that when he
provides that to you and that's all I
have
thank you any questions
all right seeing none thank you thank
you your comment
and this is the last card I have so if
anybody else would like to speak on 242
you have to file a pink card
um
and this is uh Kevin Daigle from the New
Hampshire Grocers Association he opposes
the bill and asks for up to four minutes
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Kevin Daigle and I'm with the New
Hampshire Grocers Association
uh for those of you not familiar with us
we represent both chain and independent
Grocery and convenience stores I did
pass around some testimony that's coming
around so I'll try and keep my comments
brief as I know you're trying to stay on
schedule
uh while the concerns surrounding pfas
is well founded this bill creates some
concerns and because of that we appear
today in opposition
in applying its own requirements for
packaging New Hampshire is creating a
burden on our businesses one which puts
us in the position of policing product
packaging while trying to Source
manufacturers who are able to comply
with the state's restrictions
this is something that will prove to be
both challenging and costly
additionally as I understand it the use
of pfas and other chemicals in all food
packaging is already regulated at the
federal level by the FDA in order to
demonstrate that food packaging is safe
for its intended use the FDA requires
upfront submission of extensive test
data and scientific information
regarding chemical composition
migration levels and toxicity
Additionally the FDA can withdraw its
approval for a food packaging chemical
at any time
if available data no longer demonstrate
that the substance is safe for its
intended use
so we feel this is an area that should
be addressed on the federal level to
ensure we're not dealing with the
patchwork of State mandates and
additional costs for compliant packaging
so for these reasons we ask you to find
House Bill 242 in expedient to legislate
thank you thank you very much any
questions representative billio thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
um
I'm not sure if you can answer this but
the packaging could be labeled in this
packaging was made with pfas or has pfas
in it is that possible
I'm sure it could be
um in outside my area of expertise but
I'll do something that I can relate to
so years ago
um this legislature took up a bill on
GMO and it was to have labeling on
specific products that were going to be
here in the state
um the problem is New Hampshire is such
a small footprint so for us to dictate
to manufacturers that it would have to
um vary its labeling just for those
items sold in our state we had
manufacturers tell us they wouldn't do
that so they would actually limit the
number of items they would have been
able to sell in the state based on that
can you do it I'm sure you can the
number of states that are involved makes
it difficult because we don't have mass
production of packaging here within our
states so we're we're transporting that
in
um if all of the packaging that was sold
throughout the US was labeled I mean
that would make it easier we want a
Level Playing Field right so it's
difficult whether it's a small member
who has you know a couple stores here in
New Hampshire and a couple in another
state or a multi-state larger chain we
just want to be able to have the same
Dynamics across yeah okay thank you
thank you
all right any other questions
representative spear
we have a particularly bad problem here
in New Hampshire and I'm sure your
families are here as well
and
would you feel that it as a as a
community member facing the same health
issues that we are not able to drink our
water
not able to trust even the packaging of
our food
that the
grocery Association and the members
should take some effort just to protect
the communities that they live in
well thank you for your question
um we do take
concern with with those in our
communities I'm sorry I I'm having
trouble hearing sure so we do take
concern with those within our
communities and surrounding communities
um
the leakage and the contamination that
you speak of I don't believe comes from
the packaging per se it's coming from a
leak from a giant chemical processing
plant not from the packaging you talked
about the packaging not being safe I
don't know where that's true because we
rely on the FDA on a number of things
for its ability to research and stamp
its approval and the packaging you're
using now is showing that there isn't
leaching into your food
um so I I don't know if that answers the
question
representative mclear
um my understanding is that this is a
National Organization
uh no where the New Hampshire but but it
is a National Organization or a
Statewide trade Association okay but
you're not affiliated with any other
ones on a national basis or not I mean
they're they're partners of ours that
we're not affiliated with them okay
thank you
all right thank you seeing no other
questions thank you very much for your
testimony
and uh before closing the hearing we
have the blue sheet we had one in favor
and one against so two signed up total
so we'll close the hearing on 242 and
now we'll open the hearing on House Bill
280. relative to the sale of
freeze-dried foods
foreign
we'll call the prime sponsor
representative potusik
to introduce the bill
thank you Mr chairman for the record
representative John tusik Rockingham
District 13 which is Derry New Hampshire
uh I'm introducing this bill for uh
Jennifer Houston
who contacted me oh
virtually uh right after the end of the
last session about uh introducing a bill
uh for Frozen
packaging now I'm going to read I hope
she sent this out to you she said she
did so I'm going to read it and if
anybody's got any questions feel free to
just chime in
dear members and house Commerce consumer
affairs committee I'm Jennifer Houston a
resident in Sullivan County
and I'm reading to you in support of HB
280 FN
I apologize for not being there in
person to testify uh
uh for her various commitments I assure
you this bill has great value for New
Hampshire I participate in several
farmers markets to New Hampshire and due
to current legislation I'm severely
restricted in what I can sell through
cottage law freeze dryers have now been
available for residential purchase they
are quite an investment they are also a
very safe way to preserve food for a
longer period of time than traditional
canning fish dryers are completely
automated freeze food before removing
moisture via a vacuum pump it often
takes over 12 hours the result is
produced that his product is safe and
shelf stable I like dehydration which
leaves moisture that allows bacteria to
grow freeze-dried products are dry you
may be familiar with freeze-dried
products like hiking meals Astronaut
Astronaut ice cream or MREs
for those who are veterans or no
veterans MREs are meals ready to eat
um having lived through she rations K
rations and MREs I would much prefer the
MREs
by allowing freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables you make a healthy addition
available to the citizens of New
Hampshire that lasts longer than fresh
produce available at farmers markets
freeze drying retains more of the
nutritional content any other
preservation method the end product is
safe as anything a person would be able
to buy at their local grocery store most
people have asked me to sell them
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables and I
could not do so under the current
regulations freeze drying does not allow
for growth of
clostridium botulinum botulism the
primary concern of the currently drafted
cottage law removing all moisture also
provides prohibits the growth of
microorganisms which is the second
priority of current legislation majority
of U.S states 34 at this time allow for
selling a freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables under cottage law as health
benefits and Grand the men are so great
I am very happy to answer questions that
you may have either in phone email or
Zoom you may reach her at her email or
phone number for restaurant reference
there's a great succinct explanation of
the basic process at a certain website
thank you for your time and
consideration Jennifer Houston
Springfield New Hampshire as all of you
have this and can communicate with her
directly she is very fervent about
getting this information done to help
all the consumers of all the farmers
markets in the state of New Hampshire
and as an aside I was on the board of
directors at the Dairy Farmers Market
which is one of the best in the state
and uh I agree with her and I would have
much rather had some of that really good
ice cream that in the middle of the
summer than sitting there sweating my
anyway uh thank you for your attention
if there's any questions I'd be happy to
answer them if I can
representative Burroughs yes hi jump
representative thanks for taking my
question
um
do you know if anybody was consulted who
has expertise in in um serve State Serve
Safe standards or in say food food
safety issues well the next person to
Testament testify is going to be Colleen
Smith from food Protection Service okay
and she can take the technical questions
any other questions
uh representative post
very much and um uh thank you for
bringing this forward I have a question
um on the methodology in the end
um where it says to the extent that
entities are exempt from licensure this
bill will result in an indeterminable
decrease in Revenue to the state general
fund I mean does that pertain already
um that's a technical question I believe
that Miss Smith can answer for us okay
okay all right thank you very much
seeing so you know other questions we'll
call the next thank you
thank you
we'll call the next uh
versus the speak Colleen Smith from DHHS
opposes the bill and asks for five
minutes
good afternoon members of the committee
thank you for allowing me to testify for
the record my name is Colleen Smith I'm
the administrator for the food
protection section which is within the
Department of Health and Human Services
the department is opposed to the bill as
it is currently written
amending the definition of potentially
hazardous foods to include
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables there
there is a conflict there in in the
sense that if the freeze drying was done
correctly the the product is
non-potentially hazardous Our concern
lies in the uh the use of Home equipment
and consistency of being able to yield a
safe product the currently if a producer
was going to freeze-dried a product such
as fruits or vegetables they would
require to get a license in a commercial
kitchen and they would also have to have
their process evaluated by process
Authority usually an education someone
from a university to evaluate their
process
freeze drying fruits and vegetables
they're all they're not uniform in shape
and size so applying One Step might not
yield the same results or same dryness
in a product to yield to make it
not potentially hazardous
with the definition change a homestead
food operator could make this in their
home there are certain home food
manufacturers in New Hampshire that do
our license but many are exempt from a
license because they don't gross more
than 35 000 in sales or they're only
selling their products from their home a
Farm Stand or a farmer's market so those
we we don't regulate those entities so
we would have no oversight on an exempt
Homestead so if this was allowed
um they could do this without any kind
of regulatory oversight or verification
that was there was food safety training
by the the operator
um we do recognize that home kitchens
are limited in size we're concerned that
if it was focused on fruits and
vegetables that this could overwhelm a
home kitchen if they were trying to
freeze dry a lot of food at once and
using a domestic food that a
piece of equipment that was meant for
residential use not a commercial use by
by altering that product and packaging
it you you do
um you do limit the amount of growth of
spoilage microorganisms and make it more
of an environment conducive to pathogens
such as salmonella would be one of
concern in fact the department did was
involved in investigating an outbreak
this was a dried jerky dog treat several
years ago that sickened 43 people and it
was the case where a home food
manufacturer and and pet food is is not
regulated by the Department of Health
and Human Services and in fact this
person follow it's it actually follows
the Department of Agriculture but based
on their rules they had they weren't
required to be licensed they were making
the jerky with a dehydrator they weren't
cooking it properly they weren't
cleaning properly they didn't have food
safety training and that therefore 43
people became ill with salmonella as a
result of that product so again we do
have concerns with expanding what's
allowed in a homestead kitchen currently
what's allowed are baked goods such as
brownies cookies candies jams jellies
things that don't pose a large food
safety risk so thank you for allowing me
to testify I'd be happy to answer any
questions the committee might have
I have one question uh
under thirty five thousand dollars in
sales this would not be necessary is
that right
correct the homestead food manufacturer
who who does not make more than thirty
five thousand dollars is not required to
be licensed but again that that's really
um on an honor System we don't track
income so someone has to self-report to
us we really find that the most times
someone's coming us coming to us to be
licensed as the homestead is because
where they're selling it is requiring it
or they want to sell to restaurants or
via the Internet those are usually the
reasons why
thank you representative Sullivan you
had to end up uh yeah thank you so
how does it work down I think you
explained it a little bit so right now
you allow like brownie I know there's a
woman in Berlin who makes whoopie pies
out of her Homestead or her house
because it says home kitchen or
something on the label so what is the
regulatory framework there and why would
it not work for this is simply because
you don't allow anything that could
theoretically make us sick to be cooked
or correct so the homestead food
operation is limited to things which
which are generally shelf stable in
nature things like baked goods like
cookies or brownies things that you're
you um if you if you didn't cook it to
the correct temperature it was that
you'd the product wouldn't be salable
it's by cooking it essentially you're
you're you're making the product
um taste taste as expected they're very
low risk their their water activity is
what controls the growth of
microorganisms and in those baked goods
or things like jams and jellies that are
high in sugar there's very low micro
right microbial
um risk with this freeze drying our
concern is it's a specialized process
and if it's done correctly it could have
a low water activity where it doesn't
pose a microbial risk our Our concern is
is that there's just so much variation
and again we're using domestic equipment
not necessarily attended intended for
mass production of of food for for
um Commerce I see follow-up follow-up so
is there is there a regulatory framework
that you envision that would allow
somebody to work like is there a way to
go into a person's home and perhaps
inspect their dehydrator big yes this
would work or is it is that just too
complicated so if that if um there could
be potentially a a structure where a
license could be required for for that
and again they would have to have their
process evaluated by an authority that
was qualified to do that and and you
know that specific product whether it
was zucchini or blueberries or or apples
depending on what they were doing is
that the product would be evaluated per
that product there is a current
mechanism for them to to do that now but
it would be have to be in a commercial
kitchen a commercial setting versus a
home kitchen
I see thank you okay we're gonna go uh
representative Calabro representative
McAleer representative Gibbs and
we'll go in that order thank you
thank you for taking my question Vice
chair
um
as a retired Chef
I think that the spirit of this bill was
to make life easier for homesteads to be
able to sell
um what I would consider to be fairly
safe innocuous things you were
mentioning meat and and meat related
products this is strictly for produce
um as a culinarian certified
um when somebody is doing something in
an operation like this the last thing
they want to do is get somebody sick
okay so freeze drying really is the
safest method of preservation for that
particular thing my question to you is
um
if we
if we Outlaw this and it is safe
this is kind of hampering that
um
that whole thing what do you think we
can do to try and
learn more about the process it's doing
at home so that we can say this is safe
I mean it's federally controlled they
they have
um they won't allow these things to be
sold on the market if they're dangerous
so so uh and to answer your question we
did we did consult with University
officials at the University of Maine and
at Cornell and they they're they were in
agreement that
in order to be verified that it's being
done safely is that it which should have
a process review which would be they
would evaluate based on the the size and
the specific Matrix the times and the
times and length that it would be in the
freeze dryer to have some food safety
controls Our concern is is that there
are a very large group of homesteaders
that are without regulatory oversight so
how could we possibly manage that they
were actually going to get that that
done
all right before we go to representative
McAleer uh someone said please send out
the blue sheet if you would like to
speak on House Bill 280 please fill out
a pink card uh and this will be the last
speaker otherwise representative uh
thank you Mr chairman
um is there anything that can be done in
this bill you said you consulted with
Cornell and University of Maine and plus
the DHS is there anything you think you
folks could could do to this bill
recommendations that would make it uh
passable
so I would say at the minimum we would
want these this group of producers to at
least have our have a food license so
then we could work with them to make
sure that they were getting those proper
evalu the proper evaluations done by an
authority to to to understand that they
could yield a safe product in the end as
I said before is that freeze drying if
done correctly could yield a safe
product it's just without any regulatory
oversight we have there's no there's no
certainty that that that home food
producer has the equipment or knowledge
to make sure that they're producing a
safe product just just to follow up well
could you folks come up with something
that meets those uh requirements
certified kitchen
we we would be open to to having a
further Dialogue on that yes thank you
representative Gibbs thank you
um just for clarification
um you reference an instance where
someone made dog treats from meat and a
bunch of people ate the dog treats and
got sick did I understand that correctly
no well I'm so yes that that happened
but what usually the um the mechanism
for them to get sick is that they are
they're handling that dog treat that had
that was contaminated with salmonella
and then they're not washing their hands
before they go and maybe grab grab a
cookie or a bag of chips and and we we
actually had an instance where there was
a a baby that was probably crawling on
the floor or the same time where the
animal was also because and also if the
animal was sick then the owner is
cleaning up after that animal which also
could contaminate their hands so okay
they weren't eating the dog treats
okay follow up follow-up man uh
uh so
you said I think 73 people got sick it
was 43. for sorry so 43 people got sick
from handling or or from cleaning up
after the pet that ate the contaminated
dog treats yes thank you
all right seeing no further questions uh
thank you for your testimony we have
could you fill out a pink card okay
and the blue sheet uh we had one in
favor uh signing in on the blue sheet so
with that we'll close the hearing on
House Bill 280.
okay the next bill we're going to hear
is House Bill 645 FN relative to the
establishment
excuse me
relative to the establishment of
decentralized autonomous organizations
as legal entities within the state other
than otherwise known as daos
and uh
the way for representative Ammon to
introduce it
foreign
okay thank you committee members for
listening to my testimony
House Bill 645 uh is relative
to something called distributed
autonomous or decentralized autonomous
organizations
and I'll try to explain briefly what
that is
just get my notes up here on the screen
so we're all familiar with corporations
we have different opinions about their
usefulness in society
corporations allow for Collective action
so people pull together decision making
they pull together capital and they
build things sometimes that individuals
can't accomplish on their own think of a
hotel
or a cruise liner or an airplane and an
airliner these require Collective action
and corporations are granted
a certain amount of immunity from the
government the government has
something called sovereign immunity
and for a fee and for some requirements
the government
franchises that sovereign immunity to a
corporation
and the corporation is is granted
something called Legal personhood
and its members are shielded from
liability much
as we're all shielded from liability for
the decisions that we make as part of
the government
corporate officers are shielded from
liability it's part of the bargain
between
the government and corporations and so
corporate structures are have been
around a very long time
so with that in the back of your mind
um
with blockchain technology which we've
been talking about in this committee for
a little while
um it's created these new tools
building blocks if you will
that allow for new kinds of collective
organization
and the name that sort of the
technologists and the uh
you know the people involved in this
have settled on is a Dao a Dao it sounds
sort of like a maybe a Buddhist uh
chant but
or oh no that would be DOA yeah yeah Not
Dead on Arrival representative
foreign
and so it's enabled new kinds of
structures uh that are similar to
corporate structures
um they make decisions the way corporate
corporations do
they uh pull resources the way corporate
but the decision making is much more
democratic it's much more decentralized
it's it's made by it's a sort of like
you're familiar with crowdfunding or
crowdsourcing so normally you need a
centralized website where people put
their donations to and there's a there's
a purpose behind those donations maybe
somebody's hospital bill
um but the website itself is centralized
it's one website maybe on one server
and so a dow is kind of similar in uh in
structure but the website itself is is a
decentralized protocol
and I know that's that sounds a little
bit mystical but this is enabled by the
kinds of things that you can do with
blockchain technology
so I'm trying to keep this fairly simple
and not get into the weeds because it
can be very complicated but one of the
things that blockchain technology
enables is something called a smart
contract
so think of a smart contract sort of
like a vending machine so you put your
quarter in now it's probably two dollars
of quarters in and you get your
Coca-Cola out right so the vending
machine it takes it takes value in and
you get something of value out and
there's you know the little arm that
reaches for the soda and it brings it
over it drops it in right there's a
mechanism inside
so a smart contract is like that it's
it's code that receives value in this
case it's some kind of tokenized value a
token could be a cryptocurrency it could
be
a token that represents something else
and the computer code does something and
then out comes uh a decision on on what
to do
and that code
and this is a key concept that code is
open source publicly available it's on a
blockchain and anybody can see it
anybody can read what that code does and
if you're familiar with how code works
you can validate that the code works
correctly
so in an old-fashioned Corporation the
decisions are made in a boardroom
uh and maybe the shareholders don't
exactly know what decisions are being
made and why
but in this new type of structure the
decision making is all out in the open
and it's not just a secret board it's
the community of people that have
ownership they they've bought into this
Corporation or this this structure
that they have control over the outcome
I think I'm losing some of my audience
so I apologize for that
um so so in summary a decentralized it's
decentralized it's democratized you can
think of it that way lots of people it's
autonomous means it runs in code and not
in a legal document or in a board room
the decisions are made in code
autonomous and it's an organization it's
Collective action of people that's where
the name comes from
and uh it operates transparently it has
a more equitable distribution of power
and wealth
is typically less regulated compared to
traditional corporations
and it's different in terms of
governance ownership control
transparency and compliance requirements
so that's kind of my primer on the topic
that we're talking about now I'll get to
the specific bill
House Bill 645
we had the governor's cryptocurrency
commission it met almost over a full
year and I have a copy of the report in
front of me it's about 60 pages
and through those discussions all the
various members that were involved
one of the recommendations
it's actually the first recommendation
and if you download this yourself it's
on page 30 of the report
recommendations for Change and the very
first one is enact a state legal
Enterprise law
for decentralized autonomous
organizations to provide transparency
limited liability and legal status to
blockchain networks so that's the first
and there's a you can read the the
description of why that idea might be a
good idea
so is it is this a new idea
have any other states tried this before
I know that's going to be a question
in July of 2018
the very first state to enact a law
touching on the subject area
was the state of Vermont which is right
next door
they were the first state to enact
LLC legislation so the old traditional
style of LLC and tried to tailor some of
it to blockchain based companies which
the Dow would be a blockchain based
company
so 2018 Vermont 2021 Wyoming
they enacted the first law
to mention Dallas so 2021 Wyoming
I looked today in their their business
registry there are 806 businesses with
the word Dao in the name uh as of today
and I had looked in December of last
year
just a month or so ago so it's up from
660 to now 806. uh that increase in over
just one month
and so each filing has a filing fee
associated with it so the state collects
some funds based on the filing fees and
then most recently in April of 2022 last
year Tennessee passed a law
that mimics what Wyoming passed so
that's three states that have passed
laws that are touching on the subject
area
now there's criticism of all the laws
that have been passed so far
that they don't respect the actual
nature of how a Dao operates they're
trying to take a square peg and put it
into a round hole trying to take the new
way of doing things forcing it into the
old way of doing things too much
and so the criticisms
um
are part of the consideration for House
Bill 645 we want to do it better than
the other states have tried to do it
so where did the where did the language
for this law come from
it came uh and this this actually
reference to it in the report uh to this
model language that is in 645.
it came from a group called koala uh
koala with a c not a k
and that stands for the Coalition of
automated legal applications so legal
application automated legal applications
is another it's a fancy way to say smart
contracts
and uh they have a good explainer
document on so this this language was
adopted from their model law and it's a
starting point
we heard yesterday that we never pass a
bill out of this committee without an
amendment I think this bill will fit
into that history very very nicely
um but it's this starting point came
from this group of academics from all
around the world who developed this
language
and it's a language that is intended for
States and even countries to adopt and
I'm going to give you a brief outline
very brief there's there's six chapters
uh sections in on our bill so the first
four sections kind of map to the
traditional corporate structures
chapter 1 outlines the activities that
dials can engage in and their rights as
a separate legal entity along with
important definitions so that's that's
section one I think we call them
sections
uh number two outlines the technical and
governance requirements for Dows to have
legal personality and limited liability
protection so just like a corporation
is given a legal personhood so that it
can operate and make decisions interact
with the rest of society and also
liability protection
chapter 3 explains the potential actions
that may result in forfeiture of limited
liability protection
allows for uh the reasons for when there
might be personal liability
and it creates it explains the
flexibility of dowels to create
governance structures and Reserve funds
so governance would be the
decision-making Reserve funds would be
the capital
uh four deals with the governance of
dows allowing for flexibility and
representation
on and off chain off chain that means in
code on the blockchain or in maybe a a
paper document that the uh the group
agrees to be governed by the bylaws
and then chapter five addresses
technical aspects of dowels
such as
what is a a contentious Fork
I won't go into that definition but a
contentious Fork it's a fork in the
direction of the code
and what happens in the case of failure
events we know when you run code
sometimes the code can have an error so
that would be a failure event so what
are the conditions and Technical aspects
of that and then finally
um it includes Provisions this is number
six
for when General business organization
law should be applied to dowels
and recognition of dows as paths through
entities for tax purposes
so those are the six different sections
of the bill
um I think I'll I'll stop there I think
that's a pretty good overview and I'll
open up the questions and uh
I'm happy to take any questions Mr chair
thank you representative uh
representative McAleer I think you were
first uh thank you thank you
um Keith a question here
what what sort of entity what kind of
business would be operated here and then
you you mentioned that that everybody
that is a player so to speak makes a
decision so how does a decision
ultimately get decided
so what kind of business and and how the
ultimate decision of what may be an
example of a decision that might be
considered thank you
yeah that's a so those are two questions
and they're both sort of broad I'll try
to keep it simple
um
uh so what type of business uh so
anything a corporation might have as a
purpose right it potentially it could
own physical property like say a real
estate you know an apartment building
you could you could
um but what's tending to happen right
now is people are getting together to
develop you could call them protocols
which are not really businesses it's
more of like a language that does a
certain thing so like a simple way to
email is a protocol right so email is a
very useful thing but it's not really a
company email is a way for computers to
talk to each other to deliver messages
right so there are new protocols being
developed that groups of people are
doing and it might take
coders it might take marketers it might
take people building a you know a
website to advertise it and all
different functions that a corporation
might have but there's there's other
examples of what Dallas can do and I'd
encourage you to
you know look it up search it some
interesting ones that I ran across there
was a dow to buy an original copy of the
U.S Constitution so a bunch of people
got together
and they tried to organize that and I
don't think that went anywhere
um there's a dow to organize for um
uh support for the war effort in Ukraine
so there's something called the Ukraine
Dao that uh is doing that so those are
just extreme examples but anything in
anything a corporation can do
corporations benefit from having a
hierarchical structure where a few
people at the top make most of the
decisions and receive most of the
information that's suitable for maybe
Boeing and Martin Lockheed
um a dow was more of like a
decentralized crowd-sourced
decision-making process so
thank you representative
thank you for your presenting this uh
interesting idea for the state and I
appreciate uh the effort of trying to
bring blockchain into the state's uh
legal governmental structure I certainly
think that blockchain is probably the
next revolution in the way that we're
going to govern the state as well as uh
govern transactions in the state
um
however I think that if we're going to
bring blockchain and blockchain entities
into being a third type of corporate
personhood as we will have corporations
we'll have LLCs and love Dells
this may be uh the beginning of a bill
but if we look for example the state's
Corporation law or LLC law we have
something more similar to the report you
have in your desk UH 60 to 100 page bill
uh rather than something as thin as this
um part of the reason for that is when
we start to really look at when we
address
personhood we need to ask questions for
example if I were to sue the dowel where
do I achieve service of process if I
were to sue the dial where does venue
occur if I were to sue the dell and uh
where is that suit actually going to
occur if I and then another issue that
occurs in this is that we the dowel can
essentially bootstrap itself into
existence to it's essentially I exist
because I am
but we don't allow corporations to do
that because we're not creating
corporations for their own benefits
we're also creating corporations to
protect the public that if a corporation
creates a bad contract who wants to
protect the public against that bad
contract similarly if the Dow creates a
bad smart contract we want to create
protect the public against that
therefore we don't allow a corporation
to exist because they they are we create
a corporation to exist because the
Secretary of State said they are so how
do we protect the public against a bad
Dow we need to create a registration
mechanism this again doesn't address
that
so I think that we need to uh well I'm
getting to the question how do you how
do you address each of these questions
that I've created here how do we achieve
Services process how do we achieve venue
how do we achieve a registration
mechanism and how other states address
this and where do we begin to address
these voluminous issues that are
addressed in the corporations act that
are addressed in the LLC Act and why
aren't they addressed in here
I sent some emotion in your question
there
not at all
so those are all very good questions
um
and as I said this bill
if it's going to pass will be amended so
we're looking for feedback such as what
you just stated
um the other states that I mentioned
have tried to answer those questions by
sort of pigeonholing a dow into the
existing corporate structure we're
looking for
a more of a of a carrot approach than a
stick approach as to attracting dowels
to New Hampshire but making sure that
they're good corporate citizens uh and
so some of those questions I think will
need to be addressed before this bill uh
I I know there's there are people coming
behind me that will be more expert in
exactly what you were asking so I'm
gonna I'll do that thing where we defer
to the smart people behind us so but
thank you
okay representative Gibbs
can you explain
um how it is possible for the members of
an organization to come to a decision
um rather than using what I would
consider the normal traditional methods
uh of discussion and vote
um but instead uh by means of computer
codes and then can you explain
um what the advantage is
um to the people of New Hampshire uh of
having such an organization thank you
okay so those are two interesting
questions thank you for those and I'll
I'll compliment you on your questions
while I think of the answers
um
so the way that computer uh code works
in the in
so computer code can display things on
your screen it could make sounds that
come out of speakers right so that's not
the type of computer code that we're
talking about we're talking about
specifically smart contracts which are
you can think of them as like
Snippets of a program
that are that the inputs are are value
or tokens it's not any kind of input
it's not it's specific types of input
and excuse me that that that's
meaningless to me value or tokens yes
what kind of value yes
Excuse me yes thank you what kind of
value so we're talking about digital
assets so we're talking about remember
the other day we were talking about the
UCC and about how there are digital
assets that people can own and control
that's what we're talking about
and so and and so let me just see if I
can let me see if I can relate to what
something that you might know so uh a
law
a judge interpreting a law right the law
was written by humans and the law in it
has
uh what are the conditions that initiate
the consideration of that law and uh it
might have you know if this happened do
this or if this happened it has a
logical structure to the law right and
then it has either no no consequence or
maybe there's a penalty there's
something something positive or negative
that is the result of that law
well you can do a lot of those same
things now
in in uh something called smart
contracts there's a lot of overlap and
there's a lot of lawyers that are
looking to become specialists in smart
contracts because there is a lot of
overlap that's that's how the decision
making is is made if I can
you know keep it as simple as possible
I'm sorry I'm sorry that's still not
clear you may inquire
I I it's too long of a representative
you may have a follow-up
okay I I am a lawyer
um and I have written computer programs
in the way you have described very
simple ones
um but I understand that concept
um what I cannot get is
from there to a group making a decision
by that means
so it has to do with how the the
computer code is structured right so you
have you need a certain number let's say
you've written programs before let's
let's say you need 51 people out of 100
to decide that something is true if
those 51
if it's fewer than 51 then the outcome
is is false right so that's a way of
people being able to vote
on the outcome of uh you know a
cascading logical event
and so that's as simple as I can make it
and because the crypto the cryptography
behind blockchain one of the things it
does is it allows people to prove that
they are who they are or they they have
control over those voting rights the
explanation that it's a vote actually
does make sense and so I thank you I'm
happy to talk about it offline
um but uh follow-up second half of my
question yeah sure manage if I may yes
you may thank you
um can you tell us what the advantage is
yeah I started out my testimony that way
um that it's it's a new way of
collective action and uh it's a new type
of structure
uh it's happening right now on the
internet
in New Hampshire it's going on you can't
see it because it's virtual but it's
happening right now
um and it's a way to sort of democratize
Collective action like some of the
things that we don't like about
corporations are sort of solved by this
new way of of organizing because it's
it's more democratic it's more
egalitarian it allows people to have
ownership over what they're working on
instead of being a wage slave in a job
so instead of you accruing all the value
to your employer because you're a part
owner you you're accruing some of that
value to yourself and so you're actually
able to build wealth by your own efforts
with this type of structure
uh representative spear then
representative Terry
thank you
uh I kind of hinted to this question
before but I guess we didn't have really
have time to talk about it
you talk about how the Dow gets started
you have regulations about how it gets
started yeah regulations about what
happens if the code crashes you have
regulations about how open everything
has to be but what happens if the Dow
becomes inactive and it has assets and
it just kind of dies
companies there are things that happen
and the state can literally take over
you know if somebody doesn't pay their
they own a building and they all of a
sudden decide well I'm just going to
abandon it the stake and take it what
happens to a dow we need something I
would think in here that says if the Dow
has been abandoned what happens to the
assets yeah I think in the other state
legislation uh I think there's a period
of one year inactivity so there has to
be just like a corporation has to have
meetings uh you know minutes of their
meetings
um
to stay current with their you know
being in good standing with the state
the other states have sort of solved it
where that Dow would no longer be in
good standing
um
as far as being able to confiscate
abandoned
property it doesn't really work that way
in blockchain technology if if you
abandon it
so I know this is uh it can make
people's eyes glaze over because it's
technical but no believe me I understand
yeah okay so
let's say there's a
let's say there's a a million dollars of
value in this in some vast protocol and
a dow owns 10 of it
if let's say they lose their key or the
are the people all involved uh you know
die that 10 becomes unusable it becomes
like lost forever and the value accrues
to everybody else in the in the program
it's different than what you're saying I
understand it's different yeah what I'm
saying is let's say the Dow decided to
get together they you know four guys got
the I don't know ten guys got together
created a dow and they wanted to buy
land
all four of them died in an airplane
crash who gets the land I think that
would be governed by what would because
it's you're talking about physical real
world property at that point it would it
would uh be governed by what happens now
anyway right shouldn't this thing say
something
we're open to suggestions yeah
representative Terry yes thank you
um
let me preface my question by saying
that um if if I'm going to be asked to
to act on a particular piece of
legislation it's really important that I
try to understand it as best I can and I
mean this very sincerely that when I
when I'm looking at you and listening to
you I'm I'm hearing some of my uh uh my
my friends in college who were uh on the
engineering tract and their brains
worked in a certain way and they they
were very good at being able to describe
in their own language in their own lingo
what it is that they were saying but for
those of us who are in the liberal arts
uh economics and so forth we would our
ours would glaze over so thinking back
to when I was in elementary school the
way that I learned uh was by reading
words but then seeing references being
made to illustrations or figures and I'm
wondering if you could help me and
perhaps some of the others of us who are
not as far along as uh representative
Philo with his incredibly impressive
cerebral questions that our PhD level
and have yes obviously yes and and and
maybe do like an illustration an example
of what a Dao is and how it would
function so that I could see this in
pictures okay I don't need photographs
they're visual will actually work
through the do a basic presentation of
How It's formed and how it works that
would get be me Beyond first grade to at
least second grade absolutely uh I can't
is that possible it is possible maybe
even uh because I know you can teach I
mean you're doing it with words yeah but
visual learning visual visual I'll work
on that with you and we'll share it with
thank you I really appreciate it I think
there'd be great value too not only
people on this the members of this
committee but the the members of the
general public who are going to want to
understand this based on what you're
telling us about decentralization and
democratization of processes
so
uh this was actually to address uh
representative Gibbs question but I
think I can do it as a what do you
believe would you believe that a
blockchain is a block of information
that is then chained together
in a chain of information but it is
can't be changed because it has to exist
on a number of computers
all of which have to check each other's
work and if the computers don't check
each other's work in such a way as to
make sure that it's right they reject it
so that the record can't be changed and
that makes sure that we're not creating
a falsified record this is different
than if I write it down
I can write down anything but if
everybody if all the computers have to
agree then it's harder to falsify the
work this actually makes it better than
a written record because it's hard to
falsify
every single record on the Chain then
goes one to the other because they also
link data from one to the other they
also have the benefit of existing on
every computer in the network so that if
even if one computer tried to falsify it
we have the other say 49 computers on
the network to be able to check the work
off from so that also helps to create
this immutable record that's why it's a
value would you believe that
representative women I would believe
that and uh thank you for responding to
that so is to follow that line of
thinking what value is it for the State
of New Hampshire well no state has
gotten this right first some state is
some state or maybe country is going to
get this this bill just right the
analogy is how Delaware got their
corporate law
at to a point where all these
corporations sorry uh started uh
you know incorporating in Delaware right
so so the the the the the apple is out
there for the picking but these other
states haven't gotten it right they're
not attracting
and if new if New Hampshire gets it
right
it allow it provides a bridge between
the new way of doing things and the old
way of doing things and the bridge
connects to the entire world it's not
just our state or our country it's
everywhere
an analogy to that I can't speak to this
in detail but I know someone that can
um is the way that New Hampshire adopted
Innovations in the trust laws which
happened I think a decade or so ago
and The Innovation was that the the
trust laws could interface with
jurisdictions all around the world
and so capital from all around the world
has come and parked itself in trust in
our state so this could be a very
similar kind of moment and benefit the
state of New Hampshire as a whole by
providing you know potentially
prosperity it's got to be safe
Prosperity but that Taps into the global
Network
representative Bilo I'm sorry
we look alike uh yeah I have a real
simple question
my twin sister
um
just help me understand what the the
example with the raising money for you
Ukraine with with the um I was gonna say
bow which is a Korean dish I like but
anyway
um why why is that different or better
than say if we did it raise money
through
um a crowd funding
um website so it has to do so
it's a it's a good question
um
centralized sites are easy targets for
let's say uh
let's say the Russians took over Ukraine
they could go after the site they could
figure out who ran the site they could
they have a central point that they can
attack and so you can so it's Ukraine
dao.love
.love and you can look it up on your
computer and there's the story of how
why they decided to create a Dao and it
started with a chat group of people
trying to figure out how they could help
their fellow ukrainians and they and
someone told them about how this would
be a very effective way to organize and
that's what they did and so they've you
know and the stories on that website
it's kind of a neat yeah
and finally representative Herbert
for example I'll give you an example in
the document here
um
first page item three says the validity
of an action by a Dao as authorized
under the
this chapter shall not be challenged on
the ground that the Dao lacks power to
act
what the hell does that mean
I don't understand the sentence it's a
legal term uh I'm gonna
defer to someone behind me and uh maybe
it'll defer all the way back to until no
one's there but uh it it has to do with
how a dow can uh
can act when making decisions
sometimes a doll can't reach consensus I
think that would be one example let's
see a group of people can't decide on
which direction to go so there's no
Direction so that could be one possible
outcome
I I
don't understand where the Dow power
comes from that he can't that it can't
there therefore yeah it's not important
so so the rules are fixed in in code
immutable code as uh representative Phil
I was talking about
um and and an outcome of a vote could be
no action right like if there's a tie in
this committee there's no action and
that could be a reason why Dao can't be
can't act because there's they can't in
that moment of time they can't agree on
on doing something maybe later they can
so I think that would apply to the
question
following question
um okay
um but
I'm I don't understand why the sentence
is even there because you can't act you
can't act uh but now this this reference
is a challenge on the ground that the
Dow
lacks power to act
um to me that's a sentence that has no
meaning and I I just
yeah it doesn't compute I'll have to
look at the original model law and maybe
it got lost in translation with OLS I
don't know the answer to that so I'll
have to get back to you on that all
right
representative Porcelli the last
question
I know you have a section on governance
it's responsible for as far as
governance goes
and if it's in this section just
reference that section I'm not sure what
it is that we're asking the state to do
yeah you know it's something I had
further down and it's about
one of the things that's about
registration so how do you take out a
group of people and register a group of
people that doesn't have a hierarchy
like a traditional Corporation and
register it
and the other aspect is consumer
protection because the smart contracts
are the governing documents in a
traditional Corporation they have
written bylaws or you know the charter
or however they write down their purpose
and the rules of the but in a
in a dowel the the governing documents
are is code
it's code on the blockchain and so
consumer protection we we know that most
people in the state can't understand the
code so we want to have a way for
that code to be registered so we know
which version what what code we're
talking about and then we want to waive
for uh there's something called the
accredation uh Authority that's listed
here
um
I think we all got this piece of paper
from the interoperability lab this is
testimony that they emailed us and so
the idea is that the interoperability
lab is a part of unh
and they check uh the the hardware and
software of networking devices pretty
much any networking device that you buy
has gone through the unh
interoperability lab
so there's a possibility that we could
utilize their existing
um
expertise to have people check the code
so that they can sort of put their stamp
that the code is doing what
we're saying it's doing and so that the
layperson can have uh transparency into
what the code is actually doing
and you know keeping that in sync
so consumer protection and then also
um you know registering with the state
so we have some kind of record some kind
of way to you know reach out and
understand who and what and you know a
dow is doing
that answer your question
beginning too thank you okay
thank you representative
thank you
uh
Keen Ming Wong from NH New Hampshire dra
foreign
policy councilor from the Department of
Revenue the department does not have a
position on this bill however uh when
that's because this bill does touch on
taxation uh so we did uh we did have a
look at it and we have some comments
that hopefully the uh the sponsor or the
committee may consider uh in terms of
clarification additional clarification
uh should the bill be passed
um one of the items that was on this
bill is in regards to the uh the
pass-through taxation of of the profits
from the Dao to the members and
there's no mention and the bill in
regards to what kind of Taxation this is
uh the area assumes that this is
relation to business profits or business
taxation uh the current tax code and for
the business taxes is to treat the uh
taxation on an entity level basis as
opposed to a pass-through basis so uh if
this bill was to pass uh we would hope
that there would be additional language
that would be amending or additional new
language to to supplement what we have
currently have for the business taxes to
uh to provide more statutory guidance in
terms of Taxation on the pass-through
pasture basis
um the other item that we sort of we
notice is that uh there is a discussion
on the
taxation
that it makes reference to
but that it's calling out uh realized
gains so in uh in the proposed RSA
302-b21
and it states that
and that is here
it's the page page 8 of the bill
from lines 13 onwards
and so the bill specifically states that
the realized gain shall pass through to
the Dao's members in proportion of their
to their token Holdings
um so that language there online 16 and
17 it specifically mentions
um realized gains but it does not
mention any other types of
income so it is not clear
um if the treatment for other types of
what's the other treatment what's the
other treatment for the other types of
income how is that allocated to the
members
and another item on that's on the same
section uh for
301-b colon 21
um
so this is where it says that the um
that the taxation is on the pass-through
basis however
when we look at
page five of the bill lines eight and
nine that says members shall not be held
liable for any obligations incurred by
the Dao including but not limited to
labor and tax obligations so it appears
that
it might be in contradiction with the
pass-through taxation
um and um those those were the items
that we noticed and if there were any
questions I'll be
available to answer them
thank you uh representative sphere
I at the end of the um see in
methodology I guess that's I don't have
a page number but it's in the
methodology section
and it says the department anticipates
that an indeterminal number of New
Hampshire companies that are currently
registered with the Department of State
and they file annual reports would now
qualify as a dow this would result in an
indeterminate loss of federal of general
fund revenues from annual report filing
fees can you tell me what the basis for
that comment is
um is it the pass-through issue
is it uh excuse me is it on the last
paragraph of the of that page
under methodology
okay I see it
just
I believe this is not from our comment
because this refers to filing fees
yeah the the that last sentence
this will result in an indeterminable
indeterminable loss of general fund
revenues from annual report filing fees
up the dra does not handle filing fees
any other questions
[Music]
pardon me good question
no I'm just confused
are you your lights on nobody's home
okay I'm too confused
okay thank you thank you
okay I have one last card
uh bill ardinger
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and uh the
Commerce Committee members my name is
Bill ardinger I'm an attorney who works
at the law firm wrath young and ping
Telly which has offices in Concord
um our firm uh and I in cases have acted
as lobbyists for clients and many of you
know my wonderful colleagues who are in
the building more often in this case I
am here on my own behalf as Bill
ardinger a resident of Concord uh to
speak in support of this bill and I want
to explain briefly why I had the
pleasure of serving with representative
Ammon as the chair of the governor's
commission to study cryptocurrency and
digital assets and issues like these new
structures that have been addressed and
very well explained that commission
provided its final report
to the governor and to the speaker and
to the Senate President and others in
the State uh just at the end of 2022 and
I have a copy for the record of this
hearing that I will leave with the
committee along with a copy of the
governor's press release where he
described the acceptance of the
commitment commission's report the
commission addressed for a year
many of the questions that you have
already been asking and during that year
the commission reached a report with 12
recommendations and that report was
unanimously approved where we had
members that were technically proficient
like representative Ammon we had members
like me a lawyer and I'll explain a
similar analysis to answer
representative Gibbs question uh who had
had a lot of experience with things like
trusts
like limited liability companies and
like development of economic development
in New Hampshire when I participated in
the early 90s revising the business
finance authorities structure I've been
around this committee a long time as a
matter of fact when I was in college I
was at 19 I was elected to this house
from the towns of Cornish and Croydon
and I I served on the Ways and Means
Committee so it's wonderful to to have
since 1989 lived back in New Hampshire
and had this the experiences I've had
including this one
it's so important to uh refer to the
question of why this is important and
and they the commission after studying
this came to three fundamental findings
one that blockchain technology
explained in the ways that
representative
bilio filio filio said uh that it is
real
it is something important in other words
representative Terry my guess is back in
the 60s when the defense department
developed the Internet and computers
started to connect for the first time in
the 60s and 70s this was long before the
World Wide Web became apparent with
images and visuals that helped explain
it at that time uh it was a New Concept
but there were some states with their
legal systems and governments Federal
National governments that took steps to
build the legal infrastructure required
to allow Innovation and to allow
protection of consumers investors and
others this commission concluded that
this is a real technology and regardless
of today's papers vicissitudes of how
the technology is going with certain
businesses or otherwise our conclusion
was this is going to be real and it
offers potentially very important
promises that could benefit Humanity
like the internet
has come to show even though the
internet has a lot of cons too the fact
is it's changing our society and it was
important for this legislature as well
as other law making bodies even though
people may not technically be right on
top of the issues right at the beginning
there are some legislators who are and
that leadership allows a legal
infrastructure to be built the second
finding we came to was that the current
legal system
at the federal level at the national
level at at the international level and
at the state level is uncertain it's not
right for The Unique attributes of this
new technology that uncertainty is
undermining two related things one
innovation Economic Development
it's undermining that two it we had
participants from Aid state agencies on
our commission it is undermining the
ability of agencies
to enforce
laws that are designed to protect
consumers and investors so number two we
found uncertainty in the legal regime
and we said that's not good for a couple
of reasons that economic development but
also protecting consumers and investors
the final major finding we came to was
uh that New Hampshire as a state
should take a leading role in developing
certainty and developing Innovations in
our legal system that will support the
positive
stable good development of this
technology and hopefully reap the
benefits of having a message out in the
economy that this is a forward-looking
state this state drafts good laws that
are modern and balanced and we want to
be in that state because they understand
what we need in order to innovate and go
forward those were our three findings on
this when we make 12 specific
recommendations the questions that
you're asking are exactly the ones that
came up in our commission the confusion
representative Herbert that you are have
expressed and I've heard you with your
with the light on this is new it same
thing happened to me uh on this
commission but what we ended up
recommending is the very first
recommendation was New Hampshire should
adopt a law that establishes legal
status for these distributed or
decentralized Enterprises organization
that are right now proliferating out on
the internet they are alive they're
happening but it's so uncertain that the
state who takes the creative lead role
in building this infrastructure is going
to see benefits that's the view of this
commission the governor thanked us for
our our work and also said we should
work together to get these
recommendations done to it is a credit
to representative Ammon that he
introduced this bill this bill is not
the final answer when I came before as a
lobbyist before this Committee in the
and representative hunt was the chair
then too in the early in early 2000s to
propose an 80 to 90 page
modernization of our trust laws trust
laws that were created in some cases in
the 1600s we worked very hard with
subcommittees with committed members in
both the house and the Senate and we did
achieve enactment of those laws and
right now if you travel around the world
around this country people will say that
this is a leading state to protect your
family to establish trust for your pet
uh if you because other states don't
permit that we were a leader and it's
it's been it's attracted families and
developments to this state my uh my hope
is that that the passion that you hear
me speaking with as chair of this
commission I'm 62 years old and I
undertook this on a voluntary basis
after request of the governor and I
loved working with everyone on that
commission it was a wonderful experience
is that this committee will take that
important step on this bill
to establish the working group that is
necessary to build the creative answer
representative Ammon did not start with
Wyoming's approach which has been panned
because it's legally not really
consistent with what is happening out in
the wild and and he started with an
academic leadership uh position that
hopefully this hearing today will send
the signal to the world that's
developing out there that has a
capitalization that is growing and it's
up and down but just like the internet
was you know remember pets.com it goes
up and down but look at what it is today
our most important economic companies
our tech companies working with the
internet and so my urge to the committee
my ask my my respectful request is that
you move forward with this bill to make
it better to develop an amendment that
addresses the questions you're asking I
promise you that I will be participating
in that effort as a member of the public
and I hope it is very important that
this bill go forward I would like to
finally address quickly
the the question of tax I wanted to say
back in the early 90s I was there one of
the there's a specific recommendation on
tax that would uh apply and I will I
will work with the dra on that it is in
fact where organizations are serving as
Financial intermediaries alone they get
the same treatment that our business
profit Stacks our business Enterprise
tag already provides to other Financial
intermediary entities and I know that
because I was a lobbyist I wrote those
rules and it was enacted in this
legislature so that's the intent of the
the you know the uh that there's
recommendations I urge each of you
well the great thing is I'm looking at
representative Terry's comment we took
the time it's the first report across
the country that tried to build a set of
plain language definitions for each of
the concepts that representative Ammon
was Raising uh I urge you to take a look
at it and to participate uh in
criticizing it and making it better
because
this bill one of the things it does is
it requires organizations that are going
to go out there alive and attract
participants regular people with
computers around the world who connect
to the internet that you have to use
plain language in describing your
operating rules your voting requirements
your governance issues that is an
innovation in the legal system that we
hope will be part of a final bill I
thank you for the chance uh uh Mr chair
of this commission committee for the to
take a shot an initial shot at this and
I urge this commission committee to make
sure this Bill gets a good look at in a
nice working group like I know has often
been the case in the Commerce Committee
thank you sir and I'd be happy to answer
any questions
Mr Andrew thank you for your testimony
it was extremely enlightening
are there any questions
thank you
okay
yes representative
um I'm I'm you know but I don't I'm not
a machine what is what Ammon what did
you say machine code reader or something
like that I didn't even know what that
meant and I still don't but I'm a little
uh I'm a little skeptical
just by nature and I have noticed that
there is a lot of pro here
and almost no con
and so I find that to be out of balance
and and I'm surprised by it because this
is very very uh different
and and so I'm just expressing my my uh
inability to I think I think the
question is no would you believe we are
not getting a a fair and balanced
presentation that's a comment
would you believe no well I don't
believe I don't do that gentlemen we're
not here to disparage the witnesses
I'm not disparaging not at all you're
judging that you're judging the
testimony as being unfair and and
dishonest and that's not what we're
doing no I did not mean to imply this
place by the way
just kidding
I'm sure I would just like to say I
don't take anything uh at verse from the
comments in fact legislators are
supposed to be skeptical I was even
though I was 19 years old when I was in
here representative Herbert
uh in your lifetime you have seen things
move from uh
albums to CDs you have seen things
before that the original internet you
would have been very skeptical of
because it was communicating without any
kind of Assistance or graphical
interface right now you turn on your
computer and you can go to look at what
that vacation spot might look like that
you and your family may be going to I
would urge you to be skeptical
representative Herbert but I would urge
you also to listen to the possibility
that New Hampshire may have an
opportunity here and that's what I think
I would suggest uh number one I think
you should be skeptical but number two
There's an opportunity here for people
who studied this for a whole year that's
their conclusion and I and we urge you
to participate with us no thank you
okay thank you representative uh Mr
ardinger would you believe that I in
another lifetime had a node on the
arpanet
I know exactly what you're talking about
yes sir that's that's that's the
beginning that was the beginning and I
worked at digital yep that oh fantastic
I represented digital when they were
here okay thank you very much thank you
this was very interesting I appreciate
it and I have no more pink cards uh blue
sheet I have three yeses and right now
HP 645
I had submitted a pink card sir I did
have never seen it uh did you see a lot
of pink card
Tim Connolly
put a Secretary of State's office yes
I'm sorry that's quite all right sir
thank you Mr chairman and I'll be very
brief um oh thank you um
uh since the Secretary of State the
secretary of state is not named in the
bill that's to say if we have no
existing responsibilities a role in
House Bill 645 is written but as you all
indicated those are the states I have
worked on daos one thing they also in
common is they've tried to develop a
legal structure that allows that Dao to
be to be to be formed and that's to say
is either to form like the LLC or for
example the state of Colorado they found
that this uh consumer cooperatives which
New Hampshire has this law that permit
said as well is also a similar format
that that's advantageous to a
decentralized manner of organization so
um we certainly you're you know have a
reason to be excited about the
possibility again but as the sponsor as
well as uh uh Mr under indicated there's
a lot of potential opportunity here as
you say that there are several states
that have been taking the crack at this
over the last several years and each
taking somewhat different approach
coaches and certainly that the fact that
if we if the temperature is going to
adopt um that legislation there will be
a necessity for it to have a legal
structure whether it be a daoba separate
legal entity type of its own or whether
we modify the LLC or Corporation laws
with changes that allow for that
decentralized or type of mechanism but
certainly we will be excited to work
with the committee if they're going to
have a subcommittee to identify what
those requirements might be so that
they've made certain requirements for
example like representative Helio
mentioned that like LSA form is an LLC
then they will have a registered agent
where they can be found where Services
process could be delivered uh they'd
have to file in a report to indicate
that they have paid their fees that they
are still active and in business so
these are the type of things that I'm
looking at consumer issue protection for
uh the laws that manage the responsible
for existing businesses that certainly
we want to see and expect in a statute
that will govern daos I'd be happy to
answer any questions but otherwise I
just mentioned say that the current bill
doesn't require us to do anything
um and that's unlikely that you'd form
an entity where you wouldn't be like
public filing where people could
um view the uh the organization and see
that it'd be certain requirements um in
order for them to transact business
thanks
any questions from the committee
none thank you very much thank you Tom
anybody else want to testify
speak down forevermore hold your peace
good job
thank you
foreign
[Music]
last year they had they had they had all
the tables you know
yeah we know together that was so that
was so ridiculous the way they ended
give me room configured that was
ridiculous
experience
okay
okay why don't we
all right so um I guess everyone got at
eight o'clock last night or so uh got
something emailed them
um I unfortunately never got it because
it was in my junk mail
I know and that other thing from
yesterday that was that showed up in my
junk mail that was in my junk mail too
that's why I didn't get it so
and uh unfortunately I'm getting too
many emails so as it is it's I'm getting
close to a thousand emails a day and
where they all come from is hard hard to
imagine but
um it's yeah right so
and then and then so a fair chunk of
them end up all right so
um let everybody know what we're gonna
do I'm not gonna spend too much time on
this today
um
because the way I've scheduled it is
that next Tuesday we're having a session
so after session we will come back and
uh we'll do do a little bit of
subcommittee then
I have scheduled for Wednesday morning a
subcommittee along with a subcommittee
of the other several other bills that
we've already had the subcommittee once
but if you remember there's a couple I
said we'll take this up later okay so
that we have to take up foreign
that number I'm you know I started to
remember numbers slowly but
okay so
um
uh that did we have because we have
eight early bills so we'll take finish
up those subcommittees and then we'll
have some more discussion on this bill
um and if it's ready at that time then
we can exec it on Wednesday and if not
then Thursday which is D-Day where we
have to have everything done
um that that day will be opened up for
the whole day for us to figure it out
okay okay so
um in terms of where we're at in this
bill
um obviously I I just got finally just
get it and then unfortunately we have no
no red printers no you know red ink
um and for those of you who got it you
probably noticed that they did some
stuff in red ink which means when you
when I got it printed here it's um it
was gray not red
um I I have shaking down one of the
lobbyists for a red version uh so I do
have the red version however I before I
get too deeply into going through this
whole thing I wanted to have the Liquor
Commission review it so that will be the
first primaries to have the Liquor
Commission and go through the whole
thing however having said that there is
a couple of things that I have right now
the block have kind of noticed and so we
can discuss those and then we can take
up the rest of it
come next Tuesday
so first page
this independent lab requirements and
everything can can I can we do that by
rule
please
have the department do it by rule
I'm looking at you because you didn't
like rules
he already told me he didn't like rules
before but is that all right yes I'm
looking at you and I just you know I
said okay that the Liquor Commission
will generate the rules
um related to who these Independents are
well I would just assume to have it done
by rules okay
um because I'm not sure I'm not sure in
rules they're going to be worrying about
uh controlling interests in three and
three is of us or any single cat you
know in terms of the word independent
means really independent you really
you've never owned anything you never
got involved you know that's what
independent means to me but obviously
that can be addressed in the rules
hearing
um so I want that to be done by Rules by
the commission
um
what's that
what's retained
why are we going to retain this
right I'm just saying that when if and
when no not our rules
the rules hearing through the it would
be the new title which um you know the
liquor cannabis Commission
we then look at uh generating the rules
for what is an independent lab
okay rather than putting it in statute
so
um the next thing that I noticed that I
want to revisit is the
um
tax situation
and right now it has reference to the
rooms and meals tax
and I don't I don't I don't a I don't
like the idea we reference rooms in real
estate because rooms and bills tax
changes so the last thing I want to do
is be changing taxes around
um and so what I was going to suggest
and this is you know obviously up for
discussion for everybody is
um right now our rooms and taxes eight
and a half percent
but uh what I have in front of me now is
what other states have done in terms of
Taxation
uh if in a in a perfect world if we were
to again try to compare it to industries
that we do now
um in in terms of the beer tax the 30
cents a gallon is is collected long
before uh you know it's before you buy
your beer that tax has already been paid
um and then it's done at the easiest way
to do this is to have enforcement you
know the commission's enforcement to be
able to track what they see and what
scene they see going out the door what
they can track so you want to track do
uh do some taxation at that level so our
30 cents a gallon is done at that level
the uh for instance that five percent
that we were talking about the wine that
is done again at the winery they're
they're they're going to uh be paying
that tax to the commission so what I was
thinking is I I uh the state that is
most our sister states that is the issue
of whether we when we set up a tax rate
that we want to be somewhat close
Vermont is 14 percent
uh in Massachusetts is uh 10.75 which I
was a little struck by because I thought
there was another local tax on top of it
but I don't know and
Maine
which is our closest neighbor
has not only they they have a 10 percent
tax at the retail price
but then they have
335 dollars a pound for the flower
buds I guess
49 a pound for the trim
and the only thing I can imagine is the
trim is that means they took the stems
and seeds out of the flower
does anybody know
right
this is something I'm recommending to
change in the amendment the amendment
you read it right
no I'm asking you guys what you think
I'm asking you what do you think if we
were to change our tax to five percent
okay what would you like to hear about
the changes uh who would like to
describe all the changes
okay
I already said we're gonna have to go
through it
thank you Mr chairman committee good to
see you again
for the record Matt Simon I work for
Prime ATC and I want to clarify that I
am not authorized to speak on behalf of
all members of the Coalition but I will
do my best to describe the amendment and
the positions that we have discussed and
the reasons for them to such an extent
that I understand them myself
so just a very brief overview of the
amendment I don't want to go through it
with a fine-tooth comb but the first
section at the top just adds changes the
the definition of the Liquor Commission
to change the name
to the liquor and cannabis commission
that was borrowed from the amendment
that was offered in this committee
the second chunk of text is the
independent lab requirement
this was text that was included in the
coalition's original draft it was not
included in the introduced version of HB
as a coalition many of us thought these
were important Provisions to consider if
the committee chooses to reject them we
understand that we would push for these
things in rule making in all likelihood
or at least I would
um but just to describe the section as
you see it uh it it requires in statute
that no Testing Lab have a Financial or
that yeah no cannabis testing facility
or individual with a controlling
interest and a cannabis testing facility
so I have a direct or indirect financial
interest and an ATC a retail store or
any other cannabis facility and we just
think that's that's basic sense if
people are going to have confidence in
the testing system it does need to be
independent there are too many
incentives for a company to try to sell
tainted product if they have a massive
batch of flour that gets contaminated
with mold that's a lot of value that
they have to destroy and if nobody
polices that then it could happen
the rest of the section we chose to
leave that in for this draft for your
consideration these were the
anti-oligopoly provisions that were in
the original
Amendment again mimicking other states
Massachusetts allows
no more than three establishments of any
single category
still on the first page it's still in
the independent lab requirement
Financial interests prohibited is the
name of the section
so Roman numeral One deals with the
testing facilities requiring them to be
independent
uh the rest of that section is designed
to prohibit excessive Market
concentration understanding that the
market is of a relatively known size
uh back to the question of do we want
five companies to make all the money or
do we want the economic
opportunities to be more broadly
distributed this would require at least
the beginning there would be a broad
distribution of economic opportunities
and then there could be consolidation of
the market after that uh so that an a
person or entity could have up to 20
percent of of
of operational facilities so this is
based on Provisions that have been found
to be intelligent in other states for
the purpose of keeping Out quote unquote
big marijuana unethical large
corporations that might try to wreak
havoc in New Hampshire cannabis and not
be committed to the the values that the
general court may want actors in that
market to be contributed so I'd
encourage you to just review that uh we
wanted it to be considered and that's
all we're asking is that it be
considered
those are the only additions the rest of
it is a language that's been removed or
slightly tweaked from the introduced
version of House Bill 639 so that Bill's
already had a public hearing I don't
feel that I need to read all of this
Liquor Commission or I'm sorry cannabis
commission has been deleted the
establishment of the Cannabis
commission's been deleted it's replaced
with
the liquor and cannabis Commission
and
it simply provides much more statutory
guidance and independent oversight in
the form of the independent Advisory
Board
as we discussed previously
the home cultivation provisions and all
references to them have been removed the
annulment and re-sentencing Provisions
have been removed
which page are you at now I'm not
anywhere I went back to generally
describing what what you see and now we
can scroll through
if you like beginning on
you know where it says red language to
be removed that's where the bill
actually starts right
so this this first section uh deals with
the fund administered by the Department
of Health Human Services
this is a piece that uh I believe DHHS
and new Futures feels very important
that there be a fund
and that there be allocations for a
number of reasons Roman numeral five uh
allocations used for the following
evidence-based voluntary programs for
substance abuse related education
prevention treatment recovery
mental health treatment funding and
training to Foster an informed
adequately paid Behavioral Health
Workforce and scientifically and
medically accurate public education
campaigns
and it also requires a report on on that
fund every two years I believe
okay
next we have
yeah the drug for funds one
recommendation and this goes back to the
study commission that New Hampshire had
a few years ago one one thing that every
state recommended was that you begin by
collecting good Baseline data because if
you don't have good Baseline data it's
really hard to tell cause and effect
after legalization so you're still
hearing statistics from Colorado that
are very confusing and they are very
confusing because in many cases there
was not Baseline data available prior to
the Advent of legalization so you see a
statistic jump way up and you think oh
this must be the result of legalization
really it's because they started
collecting data that they were not
collecting before so if you send more
fishermen out into the sea you catch
more fish that doesn't mean there are
more fish and that creates a pretty
distorted picture so this was just a
recommendation of the study commission
and and of pretty much everybody they
heard from that you want to have this
Baseline data and start collecting it as
quickly as you can
next we get into the regulation of
cannabis chapter 318f the definitions
I'm not going to read all the
definitions
now we're on page
bottom of page two
is where the definitions begin 318 F1
if anybody has any questions I'm I'm
happy to try to answer them the only one
that's really new is the the Dual use
certificate
which is part of the transfer of the
therapeutic cannabis program it would
allow atcs to serve the adult use Market
if they qualify for a dual use
certificate and there are rules and
regulations around how that would happen
so possession limit deleted all the
references to plants
and I'll note that the possession limit
was was simply modeled from last year's
HB 1598
the four ounces 10 grams
Etc
okay so I'm on page four now
yes I've made it through
to the bottom of page four no questions
so far so
there's the restrictions on personal
cultivation that all comes out
F3 comes out
F4 no person shall smoke cannabis in a
public place
that five uh
provides a penalty for consuming
cannabis while operating a moving
vehicle and I would clarify that that is
not a penalty for impaired driving it is
already a crime to drive while impaired
by cannabis or any other substance this
is
a lower threshold of easy to prove
somebody was consuming while they were
driving creating a risk so this is a
lesser crime that is easier to prove
than an impaired driving case
because they can smell it or what's the
what makes it easier
um it determining impairment
is a challenge right
um
we have drug recognition experts who are
trained to be able to evaluate
impairment and if somebody's suspect of
impaired driving there's a process and
and they go through that they could have
a blood test
um but if somebody's smoking a joint
walk driving down the road and the cop
sees them this would
that would in and of itself be be an
offense got it
F6
cannabis accessories authorize this
would allow for
sale of
accessories paraphernalia to individuals
21 and older
and it would give the liquor and
cannabis commission authority to
enact reasonable regulations for
What accessories are
the sale of accessories today that's
legal
well I guess it depends on what it is
I agree with that I think it depends on
what it is there are a number of stores
that sell a wide range of accessories
um some accessories could potentially be
used in extractions and could be
dangerous so I I think having some rules
and at least the authority to make those
rules make sense I'm not immediately
aware of any
dangerous accessories but
some people do use accessories that are
probably dangerous they could contain
metal or other other lead I'm sorry it
contain cheap metal that contains leader
or whatever so like in the interest of
consumer protection and health this is a
probably a good authority to have don't
make it Chinese
yeah it actually is an issue people buy
cheap Vape cartridges uh in bulk from
China and they're made with a very cheap
I remember that with the toys they were
talking about the toys that from China
that some toys were made with lit or
yeah so even if you get yourself
something what's wrong with it even if
you have your cannabis oil 100 tested
completely free of contaminants it can
take on contaminants by leaching them
out of the
the bad Hardware
okay
F7 deals with odor and personal
possession and suggests that they are
not
grounds for a search
and this is something there's case law
on this and other states have done this
I'm not an expert on it I was hoping
Paul Toomey would be here in case
anybody had questions
but it also clarifies that that section
does not prevent them in any way from
conducting impairment tests or uh trying
to determine if somebody's impaired
now if it was the Cannabis commission
that's absolutely gone
some of this language might want to be
re-included in some way but it it uh
it just all goes away in this draft you
have a question Jason well uh instead of
stepping through all 40 pages of this
thing can we just stipulate that any
further uh changes being offered right
now or simply to remove references to
homegirl and annulment
evidently Jay would want to go through
the whole building no not the whole
[Laughter]
thing
I'm happy to resort to skimming if
that's more helpful well I'm using this
opportunity to number my pages but
so so obviously there's nothing really
changed too much in the remaining
but yes
so you would we want to go through the
stuff that's that's being deleted I
guess
so
so I everything seems
um Mr chairman may I ask a question yes
representative Gibbs thank you
um
this may have been answered previously
even if it has been I apologize
um but I wanted to ask why the annulment
of arrests and convictions is removed
I believe that was a policy decision
yeah made it the last meeting by the
committee
is a bill right now
issue so that is in their committee
thank you so I'm sorry to correct you Mr
chairman there is another bill in
another committee that deals with
homegrow there is not another bill that
deals with annulment and resentencing
that's right you can't do the annulment
until we actually pass it
no Rich you gotta you gotta pass you
gotta legalize the marijuana then you
can do the annulment
I'll just say from the coalition's
perspective that we dearly wish it could
be included but if there are political
reasons that make it that this bill
won't pass if that's in there we're
willing to work with the general court
and try to make it happen next session
yeah you just we don't have any
expertise to to
evaluate the annulment
no F9 is just the Advisory Board and we
made it apply to the
Liquor Commission instead of the the
Cannabis commission so it's 13 members
one expert in cannabis cultivation one
expert in cannabis retailing one expert
in product manufacturing one in testing
one ATC rep one patient one
representative of consumers two Public
Health experts one law enforcement
expert
one expert in social welfare criminal
justice one in financing
and you know obviously this could be
rearranged in any number of ways and
there may be suggestions on that but the
idea of independent oversights something
we think is really important
just as a matter of palatability could
we leave the name of the Liquor
Commission just as the Liquor Commission
it already oversees tobacco but we don't
we typically refer to as a Liquor
Commission rather than liquor and
tobacco I think it just might be a
better sell to the public particularly
those who are perhaps uh uh more uh
difficult to bring on board to this
leaving it just as the Liquor Commission
and perhaps in time it could become the
liquor and cannabis commission could be
an easier sell I agree with you
we could call it the sin commission
you know what absolutely we're going to
call the center commission just pull in
everything
representative but did you mean still
two Commissioners leave it exactly the
same we're just going to Grant at
differently just called The Liquor
Commission yeah I I do I think you're
right I think you're right
I'm much more interested in policy than
what we call things so okay so to the
next where I see things are being
deleted I'm now looking at
like because I'm probably the only one
that's numbered as Pages now but I'm not
looking at page 17 which is actually 318
F20
uh three
in which
uh
now this is your annulment
yeah there was some references to the
annulment language in the section on
data collection and those have been for
data collection marked to be removed
right
similarly the cost of Administration
direct costs incurred by the annulment
processes that language is removed yeah
okay
and then we ran along
so 19
it was all the current law that was that
was already it's in the bill that's
being deleted okay
so then I have page 20
[Music]
um
uh section 15 of the bill against more
annulment language we removed from the
bill
yes Mr chairman I want to talk about uh
briefly
it's on page 23.
uh the section says certain crimes not
to be pursued dismissal okay so this is
a policy choice for the committee it was
part of the annulment
uh section but it only deals with cases
that are pending after this law passes
but before the effective date so if
somebody has a charge for possession
that will be becoming legal and they get
it after this this law passes it directs
the the prosecutors to dismiss and not
pursue criminal charges and that's just
to prevent anybody from
you know experiencing an injustice
between the legislature approving this
and it taking effect so if you think
it's important to remove that section I
don't think we will object too strongly
prosecutors are capable of dismissing
cases without being directed to by the
legislature that was generally the
practice in Vermont without them being
required to
but a statute would require them to and
we would prefer that
so how far does this go uh just uh a few
paragraphs there one two and three it's
all section 50 it's all section 15 of
the bill okay
right and then 16 we get into taxes okay
right
that's fine
okay
that may be everything and if you have
any questions I'd be okay well then I
want to go after section 17.
so I'm on page 23.
and
this is where the taxation is the
wrapped around the meals and rooms tax
it goes from and also section
so you get starts at 17.
because you're you're going to pay your
business profits tax right yeah
and that and this makes it brings your
your atcs into for-profit is that is in
in this section am I reading this right
foreign
I'm sorry what page are you on Mr
chairman I'm 23. okay
so I'm actually that
section numbers but that's
normally how we the legislature know
what paragraphs we're talking about so
in this case
um you renumber them you know 16 to 17s
for the tax 17 18 hours the tax rooms
and meals so I was just looking at 16 17
which was the business profits tax
okay so
um
yeah we we want I personally think and
we can discuss this that we should
remove decouple this from the rooms and
meals tax that it should be its own
separate tax and that I recommend five
percent
it's half a mean
and five percent if five percent is a
pretty nominal tax
uh five percent is what we charge for
wine
so we have a history of the five percent
tax
uh five percent is uh I don't know five
percent but yeah right now my mind is
five percent so
um
but I yeah that I would it's enough of a
discount that someone's gonna feel that
five percent when it comes to purchasing
and the whole idea is for us to uh
uh be attractive to out of state
we're talking about five percent on a
couple hundred dollar purchase too not
just it's not like a pack of cigarettes
right right yeah so five percent could
be significant the saving the difference
between Maine and New Hampshire could be
significant to drive cross-border sales
so yeah Jason
I do believe you're also talking about
uh some cultivation taxes yeah so then
and then along with that so the added
not just the five percent so then
um when originally when I was
um working with the
the chairman we were discussing that the
in the perfect world where you would
want to do attacks is at the closest to
the production level so you know for
instance our 30 cents a gallon is
charged to uh the the beer you know
manufacturers
um so that in Maine also not only has
that five percent their 10 excise tax
that's when they have the flower the
trim the immature plant or seedling
and per seed
so
um
does anybody know about Maine's taxes or
know what they mean but the question I
had is like this has one and a half per
immature plant or scene link so is that
a
uh if somebody do they sell plants or
seedlings or do they sell the seed or
they sell
um or is this
like uh is this April 1st like April 1st
would you have to do an inventory tax
I'm not sure about April 1st I I can
provide some information so first of all
yes
uh you mentioned 10 in Massachusetts
that sales are also subjected to their
6.7
6.75 sales tax so it's really a 16 tax
and then there's a two percent local
option tax so it ends up being about a
20 that's effective tax rate number yeah
and that's incidentally the lowest in
the country uh Massachusetts and Vermont
uh Maine has the 10 tax plus they have
the added cultivation tax that brings it
up to a round and effective tax rate of
18 to 20 percent is my understanding I'm
not a tax policy expert and I'm
generally pretty agnostic on the tax
questions I would caution on one front
with a cultivation tax as we discussed
yesterday there is a possibility that
interstate commerce will become legal as
I mentioned possibly by a Court ruling
uh indicating that forbidding Interstate
Commerce in Canada is unconstitutional a
violation of the dormant Commerce Clause
so if that were to happen we would have
to yeah we wouldn't be getting much from
a cultivation tax in all likelihood
retail stores would be selling cannabis
grown in places like California where
it's cheaper to grow so you wouldn't get
any tax no we understand that it may be
reduced quite substantially right
but and just so you know it's
interesting that the um the beer tax
this is Mark are you still here
yeah so that 30 cents a gallon because
it's collected by the beer distributors
isn't that tax still applied to beer
that was brewed outside of the state
that 30 cents a gallon how so we do
because we tax it at the distributed
distributor level
that's why we're able to
get
right
so with
um let me put let me put my thinking cap
on that one because in terms of how we
would structure so that that if there
was a change in
Jacksonville because theoretically if if
it was coming from out of state it's got
to be trucked in
it's got to be so what we do now uh in
New Hampshire is that we still require
an out-of-state
beverage manufacturer
to register with us
and and then we tax
um tax their their beer at 30 cents a
gallon
is that if I you think that's right Mark
am I right
all right you didn't bring Matt here
he would know that right on the top of
his head
Mr chairman I think I got it right yeah
yeah I'm just I'm just trying to
understand your thinking you said in a
perfect world it would be
I guess like the beer attacks done at
the the cultivation of it like what's
your thinking on in a perfect world that
versus just at the top so we don't have
to worry about any of the stuff below uh
the reason why the cultivation level is
easy is because net means that uh right
at this moment where the stuff is
created the marijuana is created the
problem is once it leads the cultivator
then now it's going out the door so how
do we make sure that everything that
goes out the door is is taxed you don't
want if you wait till another time you
don't know where the marijuana came from
a did it from other sources and then
didn't get its original tax but it's it
is more difficult for the commission to
track and audit in other words the best
way to audit is to audit there on the
facility seeing what's going out the
door so historically that's that's you
know that that we that we that's what
we'd like our Auditors to be doing is
that when they go into
beverage manufacturers now they have
expanded Duty because they have to also
you know make making sure that the beer
that is not delivered out because
originally the beer tax was collected by
or is collected by beer distributors so
if the tax if the beer is not going out
the door you know it's being consumed
there
the Auditors are going to make sure that
that all that beer that's being consumed
they're on premise is also paying the 30
cents a gallon I see okay
so he so the realest would be if someday
if we're importing
importing it for somewhere else we need
a system there which is right you guys
so if we compared it to our current beer
model which was we would require any
outside producer who was shipping into
the state that they would have to get an
um uh out of state license
and then
um we that and then all that out of
state license is okay I'm bringing it in
it's coming in and then uh once it comes
in the state then we would get our
theoretically our tax and so it's it's
easier to do it that way versus just at
the marijuana shop you think
um well in terms of ensuring that you're
not there's not anything funny funny
going on between when where it comes in
to say and we're going into the store
you want to make sure the truck is
really going where it's supposed to be
going I see okay that and that was the
model of the three-tier system what was
that kind of Regulation gotcha did I see
another hand up over here yep you know
I'd be inclined to actually have a to do
all of the taxation at the district at
the uh cultivation level to continue
with a tax-free New Hampshire type of
model
it's all a sleight of hand because of
course the consumer is going to pay for
it in the end anyhow that's true um and
we could then have the marketing
Advantage what is the tax on marijuana
in New Hampshire and Sierra well of
course it's not zero you're still paying
for it uh the difficulty would be the
interstate commerce issue but we could
also put a sunset provision in there if
x happens then then why which is easy
enough to write if we were to just give
it to doj to write a sunset provision
yeah the other problem
um I I was thinking the economics of it
that is that now the guy has spent all
this money he's got he's growing he's
now growing it and he's delivering it so
it's selling it and then he's going to
be collecting the has to pay the tax at
the time so what's interesting about
when you think about when the
legislative and the wisdom of having the
beer distributor collect attacks is that
now the beer has left the manufacturer
he's gone to the distributor the
distributor is delivering it to the on
or off-premise licensee
at that point and this is unbelievable
but we have a law that says that those
on-premise off-premise licensees must
pay their bill in 15 days well why
because in that bill is the 30 cents a
gallon tax so then it goes to the
distributor and then the distributor
then sends it to the Liquor Commission
right which was a problem that I thought
of we could create a type of credit or
something to that extent for the yeah
it's for the cultivator but it's it's
not an easy problem to tackle but
there's a marketing Advantage if we're
trying to compete against others I agree
with you but I um
uh I I was just a little worried that if
we made the cultivation tax too high it
then becomes a burden on the cultivators
and it was all this more cat and that
and then again makes a burden on how we
have small cultivators it's now you got
to be a pretty wealthy cultivator
because you've got to upfront that cash
so I I was thinking that that yes it is
a possibility that that cultivation tax
could disappear altogether
or that we'll end up doing like we do
with beer which is that if you're
importing your marijuana into the state
of New Hampshire you'll get get a
license
the other public out of state beverage
how do you do that with that Mark is
that you looked that up yet
right
it is tiered
so we could we can consider now just so
you know this is where back when I
wanted to do this all by rule later but
I certainly understand that if somebody
if if we're going to get this
legislation off the ground people are
going to want to know what the tax
consequences are up front you know
before they make an investment they want
to know what the tax structure is so
we're I'm not wedded to anything yet so
let's just all think about this so that
when we come come back on Tuesday people
can you know see where you're at but so
I was thinking so assuming that immature
do we know what the immature plant
ceiling or the proceed what what is what
is you know anything about that tax
the issue was I believe if you create a
single tax rate for all cannabis and
it's weight-based flour is worth much
more trimmed high quality flour is much
worth much more than trim you can make
extractions from trim you can make
edibles from trim and you know I'm not
an expert on such things but this was a
way to reflect that
so that the immature plant is
the is the male plants no an immature
plant would be a Seedling defined as
usually under a foot tall and some
stores they would sell those yes home
grows legal in Maine so that's that's
the reason there's a robust because they
have homegrown in Maine very much so
okay so we don't even need to bother
with those two then the proceed we don't
need to bother with the procedure we
probably don't we don't we don't need to
do the proceed we don't do all we need
is the flour and the trim
I think that would make sense to have
those two categories if proceeding with
a cultivation tax
let me just point out that where
cultivation taxes have been enacted
Alaska is another example the main
argument for that has been wanting to
create a stable tax rate that would be
produced stable revenues over time the
knowledge that if you have a retail tax
only it'll be percentage based and it'll
be dollar based so when the price of
retail cannabis
uh Cuts in half
your taxes will also cut in half it's a
percentage of the revenue and there's an
understanding that once the market
becomes mature prices will drop
considerably so by taxing from the
cultivator by weight that theoretically
gives you a more stable uh if it's
whatever per pound cheap in Alaska it's
only fifty dollars for the mature per
ounce or per ounce yeah it's actually
quite quite high and they're having a
lot of issues
it's not flexible has been the issue
with it and when the market evolves
rapidly and market conditions change
rapidly and you have a tax that's uh
by weight like that it has a dramatic
dramatic impact I will say just from the
perspective of the why why we chose the
rooms and meals tax one reason was we've
heard from a number of members that they
don't want to vote for any new tax and
that by putting it in an existing tax
was not creating a new tax so that
seemed to be uh helpful in at least
picking up some support uh from some
members
and while Revenue has never been my I've
never sold cannabis legalization as a
windfall for the state or it said the
money's the reason we should do it I do
talk to legislators in both Chambers and
I know that some individuals do want the
state to make Revenue substantial
Revenue off of this so having a tax that
does produce some revenue is probably
important to getting some votes
right
okay
but you guys did not have this at the
cultivator level in the bill you just
had the the
eight and a half we chose not to create
any new taxes Mr chairman okay yeah so
all right
okay
so anyway we can talk about that so but
let's say at for the premise I'm I'm
running on right now is uh the five
percent at the retail level and then
um
I guess Alaska looks cheap but then as
compared to the 335 a pound but
50 times 16.
that's a lot that's a lot of money ain't
it when the price for an ounce drops to
50 an ounce and you have a 50 tax on it
then it becomes pretty exorbitant at
that point that's pretty steep okay so
going back to cutting Main in half might
be okay okay so main main is you know
335 uh we'll call it 340 divided in half
so
um and then the trim is 94 so somewhere
in there so 50 and
175 something like that
okay everybody yep okay
um and anything else basically did we
see that we see anything else I think
that was yes
okay all right
okay
we're all anybody else have anything
else they want to add
you've been voted down sorry okay
we're done
Mr chairman our next meeting is Tuesday
30 minutes after the session correct
thank you